two welcome everybody You Really Gonna
Come here and spill water on my table I
was that's my fault my bad okay thank
you please behave Terry I'll try for the
first time in my life thank you uh today
we are here joined by the wonderful the
amazing the Evangelical
haters
I'm a Christian okay all right
[Applause]
Carrie Jo is here and I'm so excited
today's episode sponsored by gamer subs
and Native thank you to them
sorry I'm not used to having a beard I'm
actually in my hair so uh Terry Joe's
here and I am actually today Moshe
brinkelstein
yes today I am Mo shave
did you did you realize today uh Terry
that it's a good Friday Good Friday yeah
I know every day is Good Friday honestly
for me really because every day is a
good Friday that Jesus made and what
about Monday Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday every day every day
every day that Jesus made is a good day
right but it's not good Friday no
Friday is the best day Friday yeah
because we have fish fries at the church
right right right that is good yeah but
it's actually it's not just that it's
good that it's Friday it's uh today it's
actually an important Christian day yeah
yeah Good Friday it's when June it's
when Jesus was crucified right
no
um
I think so actually I'm not really too
sure right now right now at this very
moment because I'm like blanking a
little bit because I had to take a long
flight from downtown Louisiana to here
so my mind is going blind okay well it
is today was the day Jesus was crucified
and actually oh Jesus you know they said
three days after he was reborn again he
he was guess what wait this was the day
he was crucified or he was reborn which
day is this Easter is the day he was
reborn right so this was the day he died
and they called it Good Friday that's a
little bit much the best Friday I was
like what that should be bad Friday I
know well today this is the day we
speared Jesus it's good Friday because
he actually
um I don't know you're right yeah well
it's a good Friday because he died for
our sin right yeah and they brought him
back on third day yeah I'm just not sure
that he would think it's a good Friday
yeah he's like that was a rough Friday
I'm sure it was for him you should be
called but forever it was a great Friday
we were like Hallelujah actually me
being a Jew they say that the Jews
killed Jesus
yeah wasn't Jesus Junior he was we
killed one of our own that's okay black
on black
run right right it's it's a travesty it
is well actually I have a family
heirloom I wanted to show you today's
the day Good Friday where uh we
crucified we speared and crucified Jesus
and this is the heirloom that was passed
down from generation to generation
actually this is the spear they say that
uh really was driven into Jesus's heart
and made the killing blow that has Jesus
blood on it yes can I touch it yeah go
ahead
it's not like duct tape and like
um cardboard put together at all it's a
really sharp spear damn I said Sim make
me a spear and I expected her to be
whittling wood yeah but I guess that's
harder than uh yeah true I told her last
night at like 3am it's the actual one
that's why yeah it's not a fake It's 301
yeah so okay well this is actually a
gift for you if you wanted okay I'll
take it on and use it in ways that it
shouldn't be oh my goodness
[Applause]
so
um
got all these hairs in my mouth yeah so
I've heard that before tell me as a as a
religious woman
you've heard people say you I have hairs
in my mouth and what contest well just
like you know when you go to the
barbershop and you get your hair cut and
then the hair gets in your mouth oh
that's what you're talking about no I
wasn't talking about anything it's more
vulgar than yeah I don't know what you
mean okay all right girl I'm a Christian
innuendo who's in my window
[Laughter]
it's Jesus all right listen oh hold on
to Gabe white clock Gabe is here
everybody
hey this is White Cloud Gabe I don't
like the games we don't we don't like uh
Terry doesn't like you oh he's in church
let's unlock the games but he's in
charge he didn't burst into Flame
or you have you bursted in the flame yet
Gabe
I'm praying right now I'm in the church
session but aren't you gay
oh
okay
right are you sure get uh are you good
with that sir you sure
Gabe are you gay
no no don't seem too short of me I'm
happy you okay
[Applause]
I've never seen someone live stream from
church before this might be a world
first I've done it all the time right
okay so maybe second world second yeah
let me get a shot of the stage
the stage I don't know what do you call
it I think it's appropriate okay
appropriate what's that just like a
fancy kind of stuff kind of thing it's
not a stage it's where the um the Deacon
stands to
um to to preach oh what's the Deep the
good Lord's word I genuinely don't know
anything about it well the Deacon's like
right under the preacher I mean the
Pastor which is the one that touches the
kids
um that's a priest
but we don't speak about that okay yeah
all right
and so the the there's a hierarchy like
the military there is there's there's a
hurricane everything right
are you alpha or beta
um Christian
well said you passed uh yeah I always
pass every test I have a church in my
life
so yeah never mind
go ahead no it's okay you can be
vulnerable with me well I was just gonna
say except for a few um STD tests oh no
yeah that's not here nor there it's a
long story yeah
pre-marital sex no it wasn't through six
oh my God no it was some other way oh
but it's a long story well we have time
oh well
um actually me and my family used to run
in like a um
a horse breeding company okay yeah and I
used to um be the one to collect the
excrement okay and one one time I forgot
to get gloves so I used my bare hands oh
okay and then I went home one night and
I was doing lock
things that you do in private oh I
forgot to wash your hands yeah this is
unbelievable did you get and you didn't
get pregnant did you
well that's another part of the story
but I had since got rid of the baby even
though that's not Christian but my mama
said that that was actually gonna be me
bringing in the Antichrist you almost
gave birth to a Minotaur literally mama
said that was going to be the Antichrist
so we had to get ready oh that's a shame
yeah
so you so you masturbated with horse
demon well if you put it like that no
you well yeah I mean to explain that the
horse human
coming out you use horse seeming and not
a horse human you're in a church sir
[Laughter]
watch your mouth I don't think you could
say semen in there Gabe nah
try this goat like this just whisper
real quick go damn
I dare you to scream it don't no don't
do that Terry why not can you can you go
[__] baby
Jesus baby
just start clapping really loud
that's a church school right there
in the back go to the front
that's a good question
because you don't want everybody to find
out your home section
I'm not gonna tell you they can smell it
from there
because I can't
I can't express myself if it's a change
I'm we're praying right now be rather be
in a gay bar it's Easter
as you shouldn't be
yes I'm loving this this is fantastic
like the best interaction ever sorry
Gabe I didn't expect all this but I'm
just letting you go
expect that unexpected Good Friday happy
Easter and may may the Lord be with you
oh yeah he's always with you are you
religious kid do you believe in Jesus
and all that
it's
um Roman Catholic Roman Catholic is that
one of the good ones or not the only
thing is Christian
that's the only one God recognizes
is that the true God huh it's not a type
of Christianity
everybody has their beliefs if it is
[Music]
n't Christian I believe it thank you
Gabe man I appreciate you calling in
from church it's good Friday and it is
Friday so it's Friday baby
it's Friday baby
[Music]
[__] yeah baby [__] yeah oh my God this
man is just in church right now
it's Friday baby it's Friday baby
[__] my mouth is clean [__] in my
[__] [__]
is struck to death
put poop in my eyes and give me pink eye
mouth the N word whoa
okay yeah he he doesn't wanna he doesn't
talk about it anymore okay is saying
[__] in Church's sin because no I say it
all the time you know people always tell
me they never understand why I curse so
much but if you really think about it
God made all people and people made
words and curse words aren't words so
God God made curse words well if by that
same logic God made gay people he did
he also gave him free will oh
Unfortunately they took their Free Will
and went Free Willy with it oh Free
Willy
and that's why
oh my goodness Terry not me though
I imagine free will like a giant dick
well really I've seen that before
when my father used to take showers oh
my God I mean we didn't have a door
charm yeah deeply disturbed no not I'm
actually quite um
Disturbed okay okay fair enough
hey Gabe
anyway I I I I I you know I don't want
you to go to hell for the show it's not
worth it he will yeah I don't want him
yeah thanks bro we love you you're the
greatest thanks you're the greatest
person at heart that's what matters I
love you buddy
appreciate that absolutely oh you're
going to heaven dude that I'm just
kidding you are dude you get like the
fast track to Heaven God doesn't God
just looks at you once he goes come on
dude you know what I mean like he
doesn't even look at your ID or anything
he just sees you and he's like
you got the fast track to Heaven I
already got my ticket
how much you pay for that nothing I
think okay yeah
personally Easy Pass back age tell me
more about watching your dad in the
shower
never watched him but like you know
sometimes my wheels are rust over and
you know we didn't have any shower
curtains or like shower no shower door
yeah we didn't have a door to our
bathroom wouldn't it just get wet why
don't you just be water everywhere yeah
it would but I'd have to clean it up
with my hair mama would make your hair
yeah so I never washed my hair that's
why I had to get kicked out of school
because they told me that I stunk real
bad oh my yeah so it smelled like mildew
and [__] yeah so I have to be
homeschooled for a little while but
anyways it's a modern day Cinderella it
is but there's no riches it wasn't rag
stretches just rag stuff yeah just Rags
I mean just Rags just Rags Rags all the
way no transition transition
oh no no I didn't mean like that I
didn't mean it like that
all right Gabe
thanks buddy
yeah happy Friday and happy Easter to
all
he's going so he's going straight into
heaven you can't deny it I don't think
so he's a homosexual oh Terry they're
going ahead all right Gabe well thank
you so much we love you buddy thank you
thanks for calling in on this holy holy
day holy oh come on his name is Gabe
okay that's what I'm saying
oh Jesus Nathanael said please give this
to Terry oh someone gave him a hundred
dollars they said please give this to
Terry show them how Christian girls are
Nathaniel
Nathaniel Bonilla does that sound good
or not yeah sure I put it in my um
Christian fund okay good are you
currently dating like what's your status
uh there's a lot of people in chat who
are frankly they find you attractive and
they're interested in it there's a lot
of men that find me attractive but they
don't have the qualities it takes to um
handle a Christian like me so what kind
of qualities do you look for in a man
um first they got to be a Christian okay
that's first and foremost that
disqualifies me I'm assuming yeah
unfortunately okay
um well I'm just
yeah I have to be over six feet because
if God made any man that's under six
feet they might as well just be a woman
oh wow um because I just don't
understand
um well hold on you said you said
being gay is wrong because they made the
choice men under six feet don't make the
choice exactly that's why I said they
might as well just be women they're
worthless they should all transition I
never said that now that's the scene
all men under six feet should transition
yes
I didn't say that at all right that's
good no I didn't I said that that she
just not be me it's sin yeah
but like yeah I mean upper six feet
Christian knows how to uh do manly
things like work on houses and things of
that nature work on the houses yeah what
about knitting knitting no that's a
woman's job dishes no laundry stop nope
make the bed everything in the house is
a woman's job what about changing
diapers never they should just go to
work
um make the money come home that's it
because that's what a real man does I'm
right no hey Different Strokes for
different folks do you watch this
so yeah yeah washed dishes is that gay I
wouldn't say it's gay but it's
emasculating where's your wife well she
also works my wife works so well she's a
lesbian
she works
well we both work oh okay yeah yeah well
we have two California thing we have two
kids we both work so yeah we we take
turns with stuff like where are your
kids are right now they're at home with
our babysitter babysitter yeah but no
one's watching the kids the babysitter
okay but neither one of you are no okay
you know that's funny I've had this
exact line of questioning from a real
person
I'm a real person
this is the TP what's that you've talked
to our mutual friend of ours TP
I'm confused I can't say the name
someone I used to do a show with oh I
know exactly you're Humane that song
stealer
you can I can't what is she still my
song she's still your song she did okay
this is tea yeah what happened well I
actually wrote I love you Jesus
whoa yep I did I wrote I love you Jesus
and then I had it sent over to a record
label because I wanted to produce it
myself and then all of a sudden she came
up with a song like she's with the exact
same lyrics what the [__] she stole it
yeah and I tried to tell that story on
live when I was gonna lie with her but
she was like denied denied denied she
wasn't hearing that yeah she's she's a
non-Christian even though she says she
is she said she wished now I don't know
about that okay or she says she's both
is that possible I don't think so no
can't be both that's not how that works
you gotta pick a lane you have to pick
you can't choose you can't choose yeah
well um I want to
um
play a little game with Terry Joe and
then I'd like to sit down and meet the
kilon okay who's that
he's a friend of yours that came with
you okay your assistant I can't be
myself
okay all right so we'll end the show
then I'm like after that and then we'll
do a we'll do an after show oh okay yeah
someone else yeah yeah homosexual is he
I don't know okay is he I don't know
who's Keelan I think he is he might be
you know I'm great I'm glad I'm glad
that she brought me here first because I
didn't want to sit in the vicinity of
somewhere a homosexual sad is it better
oh I should explain that there's been
like a phenomenon of politicians saying
I'm gay I'm handicapped I'm whatever and
you know what I wouldn't I wouldn't put
a past of them and we put them all
together we've seen Biden huh why didn't
you spot him no I didn't say nothing are
there demon pedophiles in the government
yeah I'm sure
that's a big game man they're everywhere
they're everywhere yeah unfortunately I
just feel like demons are everywhere
there might be in this building today do
you have any premonition about any of
those no premonitions just a feeling
like when I came in here I felt the
presence of homosexions well Gabe is
wondering what Abe or uh a b is actually
yeah he's a Muslim is that cool
um I love that for him you love that
brand for him yeah thank you I
personally am a Christian
yeah
you got to pick a lane Maybe
no the
hey how tall are you baby
uh and these six foot no no no stop it
how tall are you I'm 510. he needs to
transition
um transition
so we got our whole life path down for
UAB it's gonna be great so um we have a
gallery here it's a little game I
prepared for you it's called holy or
Blasphemous okay and then you can you're
good at this you can also think of it
like gay or straight away
which is real easy for me because I can
pick out a homosexual from my life
are you Pro conversion therapy very much
so yeah I actually run a conversion Camp
myself you do okay so what I always
wondered how does that work like how do
you convert a gay guy to be okay so me
personally I don't know anybody else
does it but I actually was bestowed a
gift
by Jesus okay or from Jesus
um when I was like 16.
um I realized that um my coder
it actually has healing power oh it can
actually extract devil demons oh my God
usually that demon is homosexual demon
though
exactly so this is so let me get this
straight you have a conversion therapy
camp
be uh your cooter exactly interesting
but that's not sex right that's okay
that's not it's conversion so I'm still
a virgin until marriage you don't see a
ringing my finger so that's nice so how
many men would you say you've converted
success
um at this very moment I'm like 250. you
know wow you're really doing the large
work I am and that's what I've been
telling people I'm like the true
Christian right no one's more Christian
than that I doubt not many people have
saved more than you yeah I am literally
saving lives here in day in and day out
right and so I even mentioned that you
had a horse STD but you with 250
conversions I wonder no STDs because I'm
telling you it's not like sexual it's
like it's it's divine right right right
right you know what soaking is have you
heard that term no so like it's what
Mormons do I guess it's a Mormon thing
where they're they're not allowed to
have pre-marital sex obviously so they
just put it in
and then they don't move and they say
well that's not sex it's soaking it's
still thoughts on that Bastille sticks
if you put uh uh um private parts
in each other
that sucks but for me personally like I
said it's an act of divinity it's not
sexual right right right at all like I
don't
um
oh okay yeah so so it's sex once you
orgasm exactly otherwise then what are
you doing this and you're a virgin yeah
okay I am
that's the only way to live and have you
and so this is quite vulgar and
apologize that you can tell me to move
on but no it's fine has anyone got you
close to orgasming no never because
they're all homosexuals
yes Queen yes Queen
that's what they're saying is they're
inside of me gosh and then once they
come what did they sound like and then
they just feel like this
and I'm like I did it this one's
successful sometimes it takes a couple
tries so do they ever transition while
coming where it's like yeah I'm not sure
actually I don't really be paying
attention to be honest I have like
headphones in right and listen to
Christian music like my own song I love
you Jesus right
wow
so um tell me this then
so let's see have you ever been able to
make yourself
orgasm all the time okay yeah because
let me tell you exactly how it works
when I get that demon inside of me I
actually have to expel the demons late
at night okay and the way to do that is
by
um climaxing okay okay yeah okay so you
take all the demons during the day from
the gay men yep and then you release it
at night exactly and that's how I got
STD that one time because I forgot to
wash my hands after the horse thing
because you know I have plenty of Duties
are you converting the horse in a way no
I was just getting the semen okay yeah
because I wonder I just think you have
this powerful Cooter as you said I
wonder what other applications we can
put that to
like hell I don't know like leprosy or
some [__] what's lepers say it's like a
disease it's like a skin disease well I
don't know about that I just know I was
called on this Earth well you don't know
about leprosy was that a Jesus thing
yeah like a secured leprosy yeah well I
actually
um didn't know it was said like that
that's why I thought it was La Percy
okay yeah okay okay when I read the
Bible I thought it was a person
well what about putting wine in your
vagina and turning it or water let's
fill up your vagina with water
I started drinking when I was six years
old yeah
um because my mama was like a real wild
child when she had me before she turned
into like a Christian
um so I started drinking this book when
I was six and now I'm just all out of
that you know that was the heart the
rough time in my life wow that sounds
like a hard situation what was it what
were your parents that's great yeah
until it wasn't yeah I had to go to
rehab at what age
13 13. that is early boy yeah well
uh lady excuse me what was it like
growing up there with the where was your
dad was he involved yeah yeah he was
always at work like a real man should be
right and now in and out but he actually
passed away last year oh I'm sorry he
turned out to be a homosexual oh no yeah
he was a homosexual the whole time he
actually died in a vampire bar in about
Empire actually uh wait wait what's a
vampire bar well it's the bar full of
vampires are you slow oh that's the
thing okay wow well in Louisiana it is I
don't know about here
a vampire bar I've never heard of that
is that just a gay club no are vampires
gay some of them yeah most of them
actually because they're all demons so
it's like oh wow they don't even really
give a damn who they stick it in
okay all right vampires are wild man so
wild
um I ain't never been like in close
contact with one thank God but
um I'm sure that they will come and I
have this silver on my neck to uh help
me if so and would you possibly be able
to uh cleanse a vampire with your vagina
I don't think so they're too far gone
they're too far gone would you try I I
could try
yeah but I don't think it's gonna
actually work so I think it only works
on homosexuals because like vampiring
yeah oh I never thought about it like
that
possibly let's try it yeah should we do
you know any vampires
um Ian Ian
oh there's one in the building werewolf
it's daytime now
wouldn't he be burning up
God you have that magical vagina I just
feel like it's a shame to throw that
away throw it away or to not apply it to
more things just to conversion I don't
know can we put pennies and it turns to
gold or something possibly I never spend
some [__] golden hay yeah I've never
tried anything else except for the Cure
in the [__] waste an opportunity yeah
well I feel like that's is doing the
most work honestly because if you really
think about if I'm curing homosexuals
that's putting the population at
large because you're rebuilding the
Christian Nation exactly yeah what if
someone had a hand cancer and they put
their hand inside I don't think that'll
work no and just um my Uncle Randy tried
that it didn't work out yeah
didn't work out he's gone he's dead and
gone too didn't work that's a shame
Randy all right let me show you these so
you can tell me are these Blasphemous or
holy
uh we have here jacked Jesus
that's quite holy I like that
you know there's a lot to break down
about this image because here we are on
this beautiful Good Friday where he was
speared to death Yeah by my great great
great great grandfather
yeah
and but here he is Breaking Free of his
bondages so that's not what we want he's
supposed to die there no well he is like
that's like
what's the word a metaphor oh he is dead
in this photo however it shows his
strengths of how he rose from those
trials and tribulations
so so we like Jack the uh Jesus we sure
did I'm a little weird right now oh
Jesus
yeah Jesus yeah what sorry
is it is it could you have sex
theoretically with Jesus
of them people don't believe me when I
say that but like literally like three
weeks ago I literally did that wow what
was that like oh it was
um great honestly I don't have nothing
to compare it to because like I said I'm
a virgin did he make you come he did
several times like oh my God
[Music]
are you talking about like Jesus or Juju
Jesus people don't believe me I'm
telling them like he came to my house in
a puff of red smoke
um I don't know why he said he had like
us like uh like uh what is the word like
red like
the burn from the Sun what is it called
yeah the sun sunburn Jesus was sunburned
yeah his skin was like really red I was
like what's wrong with you that sounds
like a demon demon is in red smoke and
he's sunburn yeah
he said he was Jesus I believe him he
looked like the man in the picture he
looked like that
do you think you had sex with a demon or
something that's what people keep saying
to me but I don't I don't see it it was
Jesus
I think he might be giving birth to the
Antichrist I'm not pregnant
I may look it but oh I didn't say that
okay so here we have so this is a little
like moral quandary for you yeah Jesus
the he's everything exactly but yet he's
gay the spirit in the Holy Ghost what do
you think about Gage this ain't gay this
ain't gay Jesus that's what you think
because you have a a deviated mind right
you hate it yeah yeah I know okay yeah
deviant deviant yeah but this actually
shows God loving upon himself because
look at how we should love upon God
that's teaching us how to love Jesus you
absolutely got me because that's what
they're both the same guy exactly that's
not too different man it's really just
God masturbating exactly and we do that
we love that yeah we love that awesome
okay so holy very holy okay
the pope what do we absolutely not
that's demonic what did the Pope do
um you know the priests were talking
about earlier oh yeah yeah we don't like
that one so we we put that on him the
Catholic church is you see those liberal
spots yeah you do there's nothing on
hold on
when he started he was like a young Pope
you remember that I never seen them
before I don't pay too much attention
you've never seen the bulb no it's my
first time ever seeing them
and he's got the devil's eye oh [__]
sure it is all right well so Unholy
Blasphemous Pope what about Buddhism I
have no clue what that is that's the
Buddha that's a statue to Buddhism is a
religion that's practice in some
countries never heard of it never heard
of it nope it's pretty popular
that's it Blair
uh countries like Thailand uh that whole
area I never heard it Dinah you know uh
in the southern like parts of the world
we don't have very good education
systems so I never really heard another
Buddhism before it's actually the um
let's see one of the world's largest
religion originating from 2500 years ago
in India okay
well it ain't Christian I can tell you
that there it is Blasphemous idiots I
didn't say that dumbass I didn't say
that they're cool though Buddhists are
cool they don't care yeah
in Thailand they have these little
shrines to Buddha and then they put like
fruits on there every day as a thing and
I was in Thailand I was just nicking
those fruits all day bro I was I was
dope man there's a bananas apples you
just Cruise you eat fruit you get free
Fruit because I'm you know because God
doesn't I mean you know old test so
you're stealing
well it was well it theoretically was an
offering to he it was given away and he
they weren't he wasn't going to eat it
to the devil once you get to hell for
stealing damn I thought yeah he's gonna
be chopping your ball psycho oh no with
his teeth
whoa yep that's what happens when you
steal why is he gonna use his mouth that
seems gay it's very gay I told you the
devil's guy okay yeah
nice okay
okay
well what about the Beatles okay I mean
uh
unhauling and what about the beat I
thought their music was pretty good um
I'm sure their music is good but there's
just something not right about for a man
that just travel around with each other
and touch each other in such Close
Quarters like that and they're pretty
tight he just gives me homosexual vibes
they're really close together
his penis is on his booty right here if
you're absolutely right right that ain't
right holy [__] man should stand six
feet apart at all times like they got
covered okay
right you know the Beatles actually
traveled to India there and mercen like
Buddhism and they didn't ask them
they're not from America I only know
American thing yeah they're English and
gay well apparently
they're all dead too so far we've had
um just G the two ones of Jesus yes it
makes sense to be fair I surprised the
pope didn't pass but we got a lot more
uh the Eiffel Tower I don't know Unholy
Unholy yeah
because that's like really um actually
uh what's the phallus it is yeah and
it's supposed to symbolize penis and
everyone's just walking around and
walking out Venus you know who was
walking on that men and that's
homosexual that's a sin
unhowling so I I have a theoretical if
we blocked off like and just made it
accessible to women would that make it
okay that would make it okay
that's how God intended it okay okay
only women should be walking upon
sucking upon looking upon oh come on
serious graphic well
that's who God intended Donald Trump so
holding he is Holy we like we love him
so much okay Maga just does it for me
yeah
who did you vote for in the I couldn't
vote I'm only 20 years old yeah wait you
can vote at 20. no but the last election
I wasn't old enough you weren't old
enough but next time 2024 what do you
think do you like Ron DeSantis or Donald
Trump Donald all the way I love him it's
just something about that orange skin
and wrinkles and
everything that just does it for me yeah
I love that comb offer too the comma
what comb over oh I think he said come
on her oh well that too when I'm coming
you know uh well there you go holy he
passed Jesus and Trump so far yeah well
Joe Biden eating ice cream very unhowly
we don't like that we don't like him at
all that's the devil you see how he has
the same Devil's eyes as the pope you
can't even see his peoples right now
they're right they're gone it's just
kind of like old white guys nasty even
that man in the back back there this one
right here yeah negro I mean um love him
I actually hate him actually I don't
hate him but what's her opinion on Obama
we seem conflicted I don't okay well I
haven't Obama phone so an Obama Phone
yep whenever he was in office they were
giving out phones yep I have one of
those and I've been having it since it's
starting to break up a little bit I
think it's because it's been a few years
um but other than that so we like them
for the phone exactly and nothing else
he did a good thing there yeah and [__]
too I noticed that okay Obama yeah and I
know it's Joe Biden this is kind of
phallic too especially if you put upside
down this is like a ball size Larry and
he's just a link and just a link licking
the balls
exactly and that's what I've been trying
to tell you this whole time you see you
can draw back everything to
homosexuality and Satanism
does it always see the pattern yeah
let's see uh Elon Musk absolutely not
he's not he's no good that's the devil
incarnate right there what about him
come on he does a lot of good things
look at that body right at this ain't no
man ain't no real man that's built like
that ever in life that's not even dad
bod that's giving like boar that's
giving like sterile like weird like yeah
human growth hormone yeah I don't know
about that he just looks he looks like
uh Mike Sully
did you probably actually I for you gay
and for that reason I'm gonna say Unholy
okay there it is
loving it this is really useful thank
you for participating this this is good
you're welcome a lot of people are
learning yeah the Jewish faith the
Jewish faith you can be honest you can
be honest
ly really I sure am I love the little
outfits
I love it well you know the Old
Testament was that was Jewish yeah yeah
so Jesus was Jewish yeah yeah I just
feel like why would it not be howling
okay we love that thank you Terry
I wasn't expecting that you might be the
only one
well
that's crazy thank you for saying that
Simon and Garfunkel yeah you didn't even
hesitate yeah they look like Bert and
Ernie
I'm not into it yeah yeah I don't even
know really talented musicians I'm sure
they are I'm sure they're talented with
their mouths oh because they use them
but they sing they're singers maybe but
you didn't
what did they do with their Mouse I
don't know I just I said I'm sure
they're talented with them
I don't know I never seen them before
but I just know they're homosexual I can
tell okay
I like that thank you for that a
glizzies
those are quite
um holy I think those are some media
asked Lizzies because I actually
um Love Hot Dogs me personally this is a
very American thing and I love America
okay like that that's a good answer
thank you
this is uh um homosexual these are the
this is the uh Frodo threesome from the
homosexuals three homosexuals no that's
the first time that's a threesome is
that from um
Lord of the Rings Lord of the Rings yeah
Oh I thought it was from like a gay porn
cider
Brazzers or something yeah no well
that's not gay no this was actually made
for like all families to watch together
oh okay I never seen him mom doesn't let
me watch TV says it rots your brain okay
yep that's how I stay so smart all right
Selena Gomez Hater Hater yeah Damon yeah
team Haley
oh you're team Haley
you know I always have to go with um my
people so what do you mean by your
people
um Caucasian yeah wait I'm sorry I don't
want to be presumptuous are you
Caucasian yeah
you are why do you seem so shocked
um
uh you know I usually get the same
reaction fruit but I don't understand
why
I really don't as you're is your both
your parents are white we got you wow I
may be um distantly related to Luther
Vandross
so
um that's probably where your confusion
is coming in okay but like um it's very
distant very have you ever taken like a
23andMe or anything like that I'm not
giving no no government my DNA that's
why I didn't get the covert shots right
oh did you believe in the kovid I don't
I think it was all like a little
tracking device to put inside our skin
that's why the little shot was like a
little in your like a little tracking
chip in your in your shoulder yeah
I minded my business when it came to
that yeah you don't like people tracking
you on uh I love the government but not
really not like that
only when Trump was in office well there
it is Haley Bieber team Haley love her
this is the game fortnite okay okay yep
everybody who plays it is gay you can't
change my mind about it I think a lot of
people in here uh do play fortnite I
don't okay
what about like sweet tea I love it you
know it's a staple in the South okay you
always got to have your morning sweet
tea it usually gives me the shits but I
can't help that I love the taste of it
so right yeah I just be [__] away
Plan B
uh no that's the devil Plan B is the
devil have you ever taken that though
because no I haven't I have gotten
abortion before but I ain't never taking
my MB is abortion holy or Blasphemous
even though you did it yeah well that
was for a reason I was saving the human
race I was bringing the Antichrist into
the world oh you had all the abortion
after the yeah Jesus had sex with you no
after the horse with the horse things
wrote in abortion because if you think
about it
a human hybrid horse thing that's like a
man with hooves for feet that's not good
that's the devil that is straight up I
say to the human race by getting that
abortion watch that demon god what was
that like what was that scene like in
the at the doctor when they took that
thing out of you and they didn't notice
that I didn't tell them and it was like
real early on you know it was like a
month in so you know the baby wasn't
even formed right right yeah it just
snipped it right on it there's two
little horns literally just two horns in
the Hood in a cup a little yeah
okay plan B of Joe Rogan uh some nipples
he's like long nipples yeah that's also
the devil that's the devil yeah look at
his skin it's red yeah he's the devil's
hiding in those big asses I think so
like that's where all that uh postures
of homosexuality just demonism it's all
healed up in those nipples
and what do you think about the therapy
too much about that we don't have
therapy in downtown
is the only the only way to get through
I don't think talking to another person
is going to help I wouldn't say it's an
holy though okay just dumb okay just
play no dumb you're enough proud boys
love them love them yep you know uh
actually like a nation of proud Boys in
my neighborhood and I've been trying to
get with one of them but all right
um he's married so oh that's see that's
not right you try to hook up with him
well I didn't know he was married at
first and then I found out and
um tried to push his wife down the
stairs
yeah that's neither here nor there
though that sounds way out of line Tara
love you Darius uh Lana Del Rey the
queen we love her yeah who doesn't love
her she's the ultimate Christian Queen
uh he said for me obviously she's like a
few steps under me
um but we love her Lana passes oh this
is Howie Mandel he posted a tick tock of
someone's prolapsed anus
and you know what I saw that you did you
see that Tick Tock fortunately was that
wild or what and I almost threw up that
was crazy and just for that going to
hell how he's going to hell yep to hell
with them all even if he accepts G well
how he's Jewish I know that but if he
accepts Jesus is he still going to hell
for the prolapse oh no he's going to
hell
but I can't repent from something like
that there's no coming from everybody to
a homosexual lifestyle right that's not
right right
um
you know I had him on the show and he
said and I don't know if you believe
this right here
right there in that seat sorry oh can we
get a new seat you want a new seat no
this is fun I don't have to I want to
have to have your people uh pick me up
again yeah well how well you can wheel
you out and then bring you a new one
yeah
this is fun oh
um he was here and he said and I want to
know if you believe him he says he
didn't know was a prolapse he thought
someone sat on like pudding or cake or
something that doesn't even make sense I
didn't think so why would you even post
that anyways it's not even something
appealing to look yet right like what's
funny about like a cake on the right
exactly yeah he knew it with the oh he
knew what it was you can say that okay
you can say [__] he knew what the [__]
the [__] not a it's not a demonic word
is it no none of the words that demonica
just tells you oh damn
Jesus Christ yeah
I love that all the words are good words
this would be a little little Nas X
um he's going to hell for sure yeah a
little Nas walking around and uh putting
that propaganda out like that it's not
right what probably not the gay one yeah
just pushing that narrative to all the
children out in the world who uh might
see that and think that it's okay to be
homosexual it's not it's not yeah you've
seen that music video Montero that was a
lot of like it was a lot you know that's
exactly exactly how the hell it's gonna
be like gay just gay orgy they look
happy though in the video they are I'm
sure they were because they're demons
after all so if they're happy then
what's like
it seems like they're having a good time
being gay is happy because that's the
name of that's the definition of the
word but you really ain't happy you're
not because you'd rather be in heaven
it's an illusion exactly are they
smiling and happy in heaven they are
yeah everyone's like truly happy though
not like disguising themselves oh right
right
okay fair enough uh James Charles
I'm sorry
James oh my God I'm gonna throw I'll be
honest with you Terry
we had to photoshop this a little bit
because it was so low you could see the
stem of his dick I don't like that
whatsoever I tried to cure that one
actually multiple times you tried to
cure him try to did he tried did he
penetrate you he did oh and it didn't
work didn't work I tried three times
there I thought the third time was gonna
be the charm wasn't it wow has that ever
happened
nope he's the only one the reason well
there's another one but I don't like to
speak about him okay yeah John Travolta
oh man yeah
those are the ones that are like
sister
those are the ones that are Beyond reach
oh no
well this means something that he tried
at least he's tucking his dick back by
the way if you're serious that's what
he's doing I don't know what he's gonna
look like he's taking a turn out of his
ass
right right okay so gay uh Andrew Tate
hate him oh you hate him yeah
you know I used to like them I used to
and then I just said to myself why why
do I like this man and then I looked
into those eyes like they had and I was
disgusted you know he converted to Islam
I'm sure he did he's also still the
demon right yeah you can convert to
whatever looks like you want to convert
to you're still a demon and how do you
feel about human uh sex trafficking is
that oh God
that's very Blasphemous yeah just
checking that's not a that's not um a
thing people should be doing right okay
yeah just making sure yeah
uh this is the so this was the trans uh
girl who did the Bud Light ass yeah now
Kid Rock is now shooting cans of Bud
Light your thoughts Kid Rock is shooting
cans of Bud Light and protest of that
yeah okay actually I can pull it up uh
Dylan Mulvaney can you pull up that good
rock one Kid Rock like 57 years old
I think that might be his exact age he's
like riding away and why is he worried
about Bud Light is worried about his
liver help that's that's a really good
point actually but so but Budweiser
although I do live all summer long
one of my jams
so they did this campaign with um
uh Dylan Mulvaney and and uh her name is
Dylan
and uh the conservative folks uh the
Maga people it got very angry that the
trans people would be giving a Budweiser
so here's Kid Rock's response tell me
what you think
wait hold on
gotta put up the sound already gagging
yeah he looks like every man in downtown
Louisiana
grandpa is feeling a little frisky today
emphasis on Grandpa yeah say something
to all you and B
as clear and concise as possible look at
that bottom tooth
yuck
[__] Bud Light and [__] Anheuser-Busch
have a terrific day wow
I think they own Bud Light they're the
ones that make make buttons he's that
mad Grandpa he's not feeling a little
frisky today he's feeling a little okay
we got to pull that down Macaulay Culkin
he looks like Macaulay Culkin and
Macaulay Culkin after the drugs oh no
and you know what that's all right
you made a good point about the liver if
the liver cancer don't get them the
colon cancer will amen yeah because he's
got all kinds of things up that color
amen amen amen
uh gremlins gremlins what's that
looks like a demon devil gargoyle to me
yeah that's unhauling MLK [__] them we
don't eat them yeah horrible I like that
man he was actually a preacher I think
I'm sure he was in the black church oh
yeah that's not real you don't like
black churches you know they just do too
much in the air I went to one once they
were jumping and shouting and right
doing all kinds of things I thought that
was devil worship I didn't like that the
singing the dancing thing in my church
too but they're like
jumping around catching the Holy Spirit
I don't understand it okay no never have
never will okay so black church equals
demon I wouldn't say demon is just like
it's just buffoonery oh my God okay all
right so MLK's a buffoon
the biggest the biggest
all right uh this is Jay Leno in a
hyperbolic chamber after getting burned
well it looks like he's wearing a dress
to me right and gloves and I think that
might just might be homosexual activity
so I'm gonna say unho that's fair that's
a good analysis yeah the dress uh the
Easter bunny I love the Easter Bunny
because it symbolizes
um joy and Happyness for the day that
Jesus was has risen again okay we love
it we love that we love that and then
this guy uh is I don't know I believe
his name is oh that's what you're having
here yesterday he's coming on after this
okay
blush for me looks like a homosexual to
me oh no and what is that god-awful
shirt he's wearing I like it I think he
looks good he looks like Pugsley from
Adam's family no okay
yeah I'd like I think he looks awesome I
think he looks disgusted all right well
personally I don't know
so that's it thank you for your input
does you're welcome so um
so I want to thank you Terry Joe for
being here we have another guest coming
on Pleasure yeah well it was thank you
so much I I love you so much keep doing
this and keep spreading the gospel keep
converting those gays because that's
important most definitely we'll be doing
that and you don't have to worry about
that can we pound it or is that no good
pay on me you want to pay on me because
no pound it oh because as a as a
Orthodox Jew we also want to convert
things okay so pound it for the game
what are we pounding I just want to
congratulate you on your work and keep
it up yeah convert this okay yeah just
keep it converting okay yeah I'll
definitely be doing that thank you
all right so that's Terry Joe uh stick
around for our next guest hilon who's
completely different person unrelated
yeah to Terry Joe hate him so we're
gonna actually
um
change change okay
I'm gonna be real down here yeah we got
a wheelchair out here oh and then do we
have we have a ramp do we have ALS
access point
ALS I don't know
all right bye Terry thanks for coming by
[Applause]
wow
that girl's a liability man uh yeah I
was hovering over the button the whole
time I gotta get her out of here yeah
so actually looking forward to Keelan
being up next but before that I'm going
to thank our sponsors real fast what
happened did that oh the hairspray
stained me
Sam hairsprayed my Jew locks
and if you got like a nice Rudy Giuliani
thing going on right now
okay there it is so uh thank you to our
wonderful sponsors today
gamer Subs man I love me some gamer Subs
boom
I love gamer stuff it feels hydrating
it's like you know when you drink an
energy drink it's got all the
electrolytes and minerals it's super
hydrating but here's what's so great
there's no sugar and there's caffeine
this is what I need
all different flavors to keep it going
for the day I started drinking this
every day at the show I used to have
problems feeling drowsy on the way home
I don't anymore
Gamers up may have saved my life frankly
yeah
they have a mobile app
um
and all drops will be accessible 20
minutes early through the app okay
cool you can download the app and get
early access to the waifu cups because
they sell out quickly
yeah but you know I like the black
cherry I know you all have your opinions
it comes like this by the way you you
get it like this you scoop it in this is
like it comes out to like 10 cents a
drink or something because you scoop it
in the Shaker so refreshing what do you
all like
I like the blue raspberry me too I gotta
try that one
black cherry all day every day that's
what I've always wanted I just found one
I like it's hard to give it amps
developing here
all the way
which one
beta mango mango that is pretty good
what's meta about about it everything
because it's for gamers meta is gamers
all right like The Meta play I get it
yeah there's no sugar in it so if you're
trying to cut sugary drinks this is
perfect it tastes amazing there's no
calories in it you could break a fast
it's not gonna drop you out of a state
of ketosis which I know we're all very
very uh
committed to here
they also have caffeine free flavors
so
there's that you know I like I love me
some Gamers up they're such a great
sponsor I love them so much the product
is amazing and they're a fantastic
sponsor so if you're looking for some
fuel some sustenance a fun way a tasty
way to hydrate with minerals and get
caffeinated and all that
sweating oh my God all different flavors
oh that my dirty ass or is that the hair
dye
yeah so uh guys here check it out get to
go to gamersup.gg and use code H3 to get
10 off your order
that's gamersupps.gg use code H3 for 10
off your order thank you guys so much
please support our sponsors if you're
interested thank you to gamer sub for
your support we love you thank you
no I'm good can you see I mean I don't
see anything anymore thank you
and finally thank you to Native
I got some new native sunscreen
native is known for their incredible
natural wonderfully smelling products
you know we usually talk about their
deodorant their aluminum free deodorant
they just
it's the best in the game we're all
using it we can't stop using it
in fact AV and Zach were using it even
before we started working with them
that's right it's moved up as we speak
what do you got there uh Dan
gotta protect that Dome
you're muted then
you're muted Dan I said just some native
coconut pineapple sunscreen that's a lot
I don't know that you need that much I'm
I have very fair skin I burned so easily
how's it smell probably really good
that's really good you know there was
like
sunscreen is a really good one to go
with Native because I don't know if you
all remember a few years ago there was
like a huge sunscreen Scandal where a
bunch of top brands had like a
cancer-causing agent in the sunscreen
and do you guys remember that you can
fact check me on that it was a big thing
and they had to recall like tons of top
brands but native is all natural
ingredients so like sometimes I get a
little apprehensive using other brands
but this one is like just all natural
and I'm this is like
I feel comfortable and I feel lovely
with my native sunscreen it smells so
good I love soaking up the Sun
uh but with all the time in the sun
listen you gotta put on the sunscreen
people you've got to
natives are quickly absorbing ultra
sheer hydrating and lightweight
sunscreen formula offers broad spectrum
s p f 30 protection from UVA and UVB
rays
all Native sunscreen is made with a 20
active zinc oxide formula that is
dermatologist tested and suitable for
sensitive skin yeah that's what it is
zinc
zinc oxide
all different flavors I'm trying to I'm
coming out
you can someone fix this
I want to I want to uh do a line of that
[__] it smells so good
you with me on that
yeah
I would love that I love lines
oh what was I doing wrong
I wasn't pushing hard enough your little
you have little hands seriously it's
hard
oh my god dude
bro I'm about to eat this coconut
pineapple
what is it
it's a sunscreen from native
grave I love that love that you want to
start yeah you want to squirt you want a
squirt a bit yeah I'm squirting right
now let me squirt some take some of that
squirt yeah
this is great it squirts really good mmm
love that thank you yeah um it's made
from oils derived from plants that seal
in skin moisture and it's also vegan in
case you're thinking about eating it oh
no well I guess that doesn't matter
vegan and cruelty free you don't have to
eat it in fact you probably shouldn't
not advisable yeah
choose from one of natives three
delicious but subtle scents like coconut
and pineapple Rose or Sweet Peach and
nectar for your face and body or try to
net they have an unscented option
it's hard to top this one that coconut
one uh
yeah with Native sunscreen you get
protection from the Sun that is free of
chemical uh
chemical actives
like oxybenzone cancer octo
zate cancer they really expect me to
pronounce all this [__]
avobenzone cancer they don't have none
of that to be clear
[Music]
which makes native sunscreen compliant
with the Hawaiian act 104 which was
passed in an effort to protect Hawaii's
reefs yo
did you know that sunscreen has a
chemical in it that like is killing the
ocean is it yeah oh like when people put
it on and they get in the ocean you
wouldn't think it would be enough but
yeah yeah it's like just decimating
everybody's doing it over time that
makes sense so give your skin the
protection it deserves with Natives and
minerals sunscreen go to nativedeo.com
after dark or use the promo code after
dark at checkout to get 20 off your
first order that's native deo.com after
dark or use the promo code after dark at
checkout nativedeo.com after dark or use
promo code after dark thank you native
we love you
okay did you see that girl on the way
out she was why I'm just kind of stunk
stinky huh I walked past her and it just
smelled like fish oh nasty disgusting so
I'm joined of course by kelon who's the
creator of Carousel
and uh I'm so excited and I'm so happy
that you're here thank you for coming
out excited to be here you came out from
Texas Yeah well yeah I guess me about
the lion say Louisiana you're not a
character anymore yeah is that hard for
you when you're on camera to like drop
the um or mid times yeah is it the hard
like Fast transition yeah I think it's
funny sometimes
um to be like in character with the
voice or like what I'm saying but like
also look like this
um I don't know
but it was hard so you are from Texas
you came here uh you come to La a lot uh
this is like my second time here this
year oh this year's yeah you come out a
little bit not really no you're popping
now yeah I wonder if you're getting like
opportunities here people reaching out
yeah here and there yeah yeah not like
they're coming yeah I'm telling you bro
I'm coming uh hello
you've achieved something so uh unique
and amazing yeah I don't know of any
many other people that uh
are making a living from yeah Tick Tock
lives that's your primary source of
income right no well there's a lot of
people actually that do it but they
don't care about them they do it in a
different way though they're like
actually like doing like the little like
battles to like make the money
I just I just do my thing so how long
have you been doing uh that full time
yeah talk lives
um probably like
a little over like seven months maybe
eight months that's awesome you know I
was reading about a year I think we have
a lot in common you talk about how you
hated work yeah
what was your job before Tick Tock um I
was working at like a tech startup but
like not in a cool way like when I say I
worked at Tech startup I wasn't like
actually doing anything I was just like
driving around they're like robotic
Vehicles oh that was it you were driving
a robotic vehicle like tracking the yeah
like the area basically like instead of
collecting data in that way so was that
just super boring uh very much so yeah
we couldn't even should I be saying this
I sign anything I don't know but you
didn't say the name of them huh you're
true yeah I'm just kidding I mean it's I
don't because we couldn't even go like
over like 50 miles per hour 15 yeah we
have to stay that or under and like
couldn't look any Direction with be like
straightforward the whole time like this
couldn't even move your hands were you
on like a closed track no we're out how
do you drive around at 50 miles per hour
it was usually like a neighborhood
that's why oh okay yeah it was like even
on the main roads though we couldn't go
like this
the highest we could go was 25. would
you be driving like eight hours a day
yeah holy [__] well I was used to it
because before that I was working at
Amazon okay yeah driver okay but that
was way less strict because I was doing
whatever I wanted to do honestly
so why did you hate it so much because I
had the same feeling when I was doing my
job yeah and I don't know if that's
normal for people to like hate work like
for me when I would go to work I was
having like
psychic torture like mental anguish
every day of my life literally the same
I feel like is that normal I think
that's normal I feel like everyone hates
work going to work it's like why would
you want to spend eight hours or 10
hours or 12 hours of your day doing
something you don't want to do really
because no one wants to do their job
they have to because they have to live
is that right you guys
they're like you want to go home so bad
I think this is a unique situation yeah
yeah
but is it is it you guys find that's
normal like I there are people that like
their jobs and I know that's [__]
sure yeah I don't know who they are or
why they do yeah I think they're just
people I think it's just people that
like enjoy obviously what they're doing
if it's because I'm sure this is your
job now and you enjoy what you're doing
yeah so it's kind of the same thing like
I guess I'm thinking like corporate yeah
there's people I used to work with when
I was at my desk job and they were just
like
I guess they're just like happy yeah I
was like the [__] I could never or maybe
they're pretending to be happy maybe but
really they're one thing out of that
building
or I don't know that's reporting to
Terry
I don't know who that is right
I'm just kidding I do be like over here
shaking hmm the dogs attacking me
um oh God Shredder no it's fine
um I always ask you guys did you hate
like your jobs like [__] hate like I
would rather I'd almost rather just
[__] die off your arms yeah yeah then
go to work it was that everybody in the
world is out there suffering like this
bad I think so
holy [__] I would assume so unless you
like really actually enjoy what you're
doing like what we're doing now not
everybody can do this which is sad I was
actually thinking about that like if
everybody could do what they wanted to
do who would fly planes who would work
at McDonald's who would work at Walmart
we need um what would a song call them
uh the proletariat losers
if you say so
uh no yeah so um
well you've you've done it you're out of
the hell hole
and you're are you crushing it would you
say like financially yeah financially I
feel like I'm fine yeah I haven't like
had to like worry about when a bill is
going to get paid or how a Bill's gonna
be you're making a lot more than you
would yeah for sure yeah just from Tick
Tock lives that's so amazing
it's great because I know there are
other bucks to pull it now dude because
making money on tick that's like the
hardest way to make a living in social
media I noticed like your YouTube where
do you want to go besides Tick Tock do
you have any ideas for branching out no
clue honestly I'm just kind of like
trying everything to see like what I
like because I'm not a person who
uh uh has like a fixed personality on
like things that I want to do which I.E
the [__] oh the characters me not
being one of the curse anyways I.E the
characters that I made up like I'm not
like
this person me I'm not like I don't have
a fixed personality so it's like this
personality is not fixed yeah like the
actual meme which is where the
wait who's the actual you me oh you yeah
like the actual me doesn't have a fixed
personality which is where the
characters came from okay
um what does that mean that you change a
lot
oh yeah or maybe I just I'm just not
interested in anything I feel that dude
I swear to God I'm not interested in
anything yeah dude I just I have no idea
yeah you ever feel like I need a hobby
but yeah I just can't get one yeah I
feel like I'm good at everything though
okay that's a weird thing like if I try
it I feel like I'm good at it I like
that confidence but golf you're like oh
you're so confident I think you could
golf
um yeah okay there it is
um I just feel like I think anybody can
do that though I think anybody can do
anything they want to do I think that's
true I think for most people it's
practice
so I have an idea I'll tell you because
okay when I first discovered you and I
think a lot of people had this uh uh
experience yeah I was like who is this
Terry Joe guy I've seen like clips and
Whispers and you're got like a billion
accounts and I could I was trying to
find your account and I couldn't which
is literally the main concern I was like
having which I I get it and I um
appreciate the
fan accounts and just make accounts and
like post repost myself because
obviously that's like getting me out
there but also it makes it harder for
like people to find me like my account I
couldn't find it but here's where I
think you should be doing because fans
are re-uploading your content to YouTube
yeah and Twitter and stuff I couldn't
even find your stuff on YouTube I went
to YouTube I typed uh Terry Joe Cherry
Joe yeah and like nothing came up so my
suggestion to you everything came up is
to take your lives recordings
and put them on your YouTube channel
yeah I think it'll be like challenging
in a way because I play music
right and I had to like go through hours
of footage to like cut out the pieces
maybe you should hire like an Editor to
cut clips for you probably you could do
like yeah five ten minute clips of funny
interactions yes I'm telling you you
would crush on YouTube doing that
there's already like accounts that are
doing it obviously yeah um I don't know
I just and now I like even when I when I
go live so I get banned like quite
frequently
um and when you get banned you can't you
don't they don't save your footage you
lose the whole thing you get banned that
often almost every time I go you get
banned every time
it's because I just say the craziest
things that's CR you know we we had the
same experience but tick tock's kind of
wild like that yeah our accounts get
banned all the time just because people
don't like us some people hate Andrew
tater tots yeah
they just shut it down I don't know how
I don't know how it works I would assume
it works where it's like if you get
reported then someone reviews why it was
reported I think it's just a robot you
think so I don't know
but you like you're like a prominent
tick tocker you make your living on Tick
Tock you have a contact there and
they're still like ban yeah that's crazy
and yeah
they got I feel like they got to do
better yeah well I feel like the the if
you look at the guidelines I definitely
break every single one of them every
time I go live so it makes sense that I
get bad I'm never like mad about it what
is the main guideline that you brought
because I haven't looked at those
um
let's do a study let's let's learn here
today yeah I just because I'm like they
always like bam me for like bullying and
harassment that's what I get yeah which
makes sense because I'm always bullying
harassing people but like in a satirical
way I don't know it's not when I think
of bullying harassment it's like
everybody go to this girl's Tick Tock
and tell her she's ugly yeah like that
you know what I mean by the way people
are already re-uploading our [__]
yikes our exchange 20 minutes they did
the whole what they did The Tick Tock
the account that reposts my um
my lives dude they're so fast yeah you
should reach out because that's your
content maybe you guys get a partnership
I already know her oh you do yeah here's
what you do
you be like let's make a deal yeah well
let's see what we got here you can be
the official I'm telling you man there's
real money there she is the official
like in my brain she is the official one
oh yeah this is horrible quality too
look at this
I was telling you this because that's
from the live yeah it's so bad we don't
see her Channel
can you say hi to Johnny Montanez Johnny
Montana yeah you want me to say hi John
Montana He loves you he watches oh hi
Johnny I love you I love you Johnny we
love John that was him right there
that's why I just thought of it this guy
no if he was like scroll down a little
bit
oh maybe maybe he was like on the other
page
oh here let me go to the home page that
one the third one
this guy yeah Johnny we love you Johnny
he was like I'm so excited for you to be
on the show like that's awesome yeah
but I think another thing that is good
is you want to consolidate somewhere
else so like yeah if the money's not
good right away but I think you would do
really well there um yeah I just I don't
know I don't know where I want to take
it honestly this was I'm just trying
like everything to see what I like
um of what I enjoy but you do have like
a big dedicated um audience eh yeah
here's the community guidelines let's
see
my audience are like
pit bulls God damn minor safety I mean
we don't care about miners well I mean
we're not doing a sexual things yeah
let's look at the uh bullying bullying
those two that are right next to each
other those ones I get are all three of
those it's actually for me yeah I know
what you mean it's accurate nudity
bullying wait you do adult nudity
apparently you show cleavage yeah
let's see um it says content that
insults another individual that's it
yeah
disparages another visual you can't say
like this dude's a poo poo head yeah
that's a disparaging you can say that it
just can't be like very vulgar
you can't make fun of people based on
their intelligence appearance
personality or hygiene
hygiene can't even talk stinky I said
that all the time that's what I'm saying
I understand why I get banned all the
time because it makes sense I feel like
they just write these rules so that they
can justify Banning anyone for anything
at any time you know
you just have to go on there and be um
cookie cutter princess and they won't
ban you let's see let's see what minor
safety is
apparently you can't even
um apparently
you can't even post content that engages
with minors in a sexual way
[Laughter]
in this platform is strict yeah
all right grooming Behavior why is James
Charles still have an account then okay
but I don't know about that okay all
right fair enough
just a little gag
um well tell me where are you from
originally where'd you grow up Houston
oh so you you're born raised Texas yeah
nice I've never really been I never
lived anywhere else but I've been to
like New York Colorado and California I
think Louisiana but that's like right
next to me so and what you're in from
Houston right yeah that's like a low is
that the liberal City or is that the
year I think it's very
I think all of Texas is Yeehaw right but
there's obviously like the people I know
are liberal I don't know any Yeehaw
people right yeah it's the politics I've
never even been to Texas so I wonder
either is it is it is the politics in
the atmosphere there ever yeah I've
never experienced racism a day in my
life homophobia nothing no I think
honestly I think it's like kind of
different for me though because I'm like
huge black man oh I just feel like
people are mad like a little intimidated
by that I've never gotten anything
except for like a middle school but like
it's like everybody gets yeah bullied in
middle school okay
and what do your parents do my parents I
don't know
they just made money somehow my my mom
doesn't work my stepdad works but I
don't know what he does I don't know
what he like actually does he just does
some [__] I know exactly I know what you
mean in a way like a plant he works he
does some [__] somewhere
I don't know I never asked you have
siblings yeah I have three brothers two
older one younger oh yeah so what does
the family think of your uh Newfound
success they don't care they're not
interested no they're just like okay
good for you okay I like that though
because I'm not a very like
like positive reinforce enforcement kind
of person like I actually hate positive
reinforcement enforcement so I enjoyed
the treating me like it doesn't matter
what is that how are you right why were
you why are you like that I don't know
I'm weird I just get like very like
cringy whenever I feel like people are
like complimenting me or like I feel
that way too I feel like I don't believe
them and it's like just tell me the
truths I don't want ourselves yeah but
do you I feel like you're a lot it's
like
I'm like that yeah you're just playing
it well I know they're telling the truth
yeah I don't know I just don't like to
hear it do you think in a way that you
do wish that they were more like excited
for you no were you like this is awesome
we're stuck they do they say stuff like
that they they're interested in like
what I'm doing like they want to know
like they're walking yeah I don't even
tell them like I wasn't even they don't
even know that I'm here actually well
she doesn't mean my mom knows I'm in
California but she doesn't know what I'm
doing that's what she wouldn't even
understand like if I told her right with
the podcast she knows what did she know
how to use tick tock she's always on
Tick Tock okay yeah I blocked her
I blocked her on my main account I don't
want her to watch my lives she probably
made another account and still watches
but I just at least I just need the
Peace of Mind wait why don't you want
your mom watching it because it feels
awkward and weird because I talk about
like vulgar stuff and like she's just
like there in the comments like hearing
me talk about even Terry Joe talking
about yeah yeah mama can't hear that
yeah she watches actually that one
channel like like oh the clip Channel
yeah that's all right that's sweet like
re-watches it when I'm not alive oh she
loves what you do she's interested yeah
I just don't want to know that she is
right
and uh well is anyone you you've touched
into this religious thing you satirize
the Christianity growing up in Texas is
that drawing on some real world
experiences at all really actually I've
been a tourist like probably like eight
times in my entire life yeah that I can
remember
um my family's like not very religious
like they are Christians but like
they're not like devout Christians or
like I don't know I don't know I don't
even know what they are to be honest
they may be like Baptist but isn't that
Christian I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know any of that [__]
I literally don't know anything about
religion either that's incredible
because you Channel yeah you're
channeling the crazy Christian energy
like really good yeah I I think it comes
from
because there's a TV show that I used to
watch or used to watch it's my one of my
favorite TV shows it's called True Blood
and the showtime vampire show HBO
True Blood was HBO it was HBO yeah oh um
actually funny story I literally started
watching that with my grandma and
there's very like graphic sex scenes in
that TV show
um but anyways what was that she would
always change the channel every time
she'd just change it yeah
um that's like one of my favorite TV
shows and there's like a few characters
on there that are like in like the vein
of Terry Jones I feel like that's where
I draw inspiration from
by the way Johnny is in chat I know he
told me he was going to be there saying
something cool Johnny Johnny is um one
of my friends that I met on Twitter live
actually
um
yeah Johnny
hello
he told me that he was going to be in
the chat Hello Johnny do you want to say
anything
to him to Hayden to us owe him to us
yeah
So True Blood I know she also have a
vampire character so yeah so
would you rather be a vampire or
werewolf definitely a vampire okay yeah
for sure vampires are dope and like it
really depends though some movies like
their powers are way cooler yeah because
like in some of these vampires can like
fly there's like fast and super strong
and they're all sexy they're all hot as
[__] those are the vampires I like I
don't like the ones that are like
demonic and like no yeah you want to be
like Chic yeah trendy sexy hot vampire
yeah that's me that's that's so me I
feel like that's the only appeal
and then you like you just like when you
bite someone they want it because you're
so hot yeah yeah that's what I want
that's it I love the vampires out there
I love that amethyst Jade is your
vampire character yeah
like Brad Pitt kind of vampire yeah what
was that one the the Vampire Diaries
what the [__] was that called Vampire
Diaries
not Twilight that's the interview oh
yeah interview with them yeah dude we
like Interview with the Vampire yeah
that's a good movie yeah I liked it I
I think I seen it like twice
I've seen almost every vampire
what's the worst vampire movie The Worst
probably
unpopular opinion the what I don't even
know the underworld ones underworld yeah
oh that's only because she's kind of
vampires that are like
right they're scary yeah they're mean
yeah not hot yeah unfuckable and like
except for the main character the girl
she's hot she's hot but like she's like
I think a fledgling like half an hour a
fledgling I love you know the
terminology yeah okay I learned this
live on fledging in video games yeah
vampire fledge fledgling
the picture
oh that's underworld yeah ain't nobody
[__] him yeah never trusty ass
[__] he's gonna never mind that's
horrible to say
also head could be a problem for
vampires with the teeth true can they
retract them they can retract them yeah
right they could they do normal yeah but
then when they get horny or blood that's
literally what happened they come out
um but like actual horny though not
horny for blood but that's it was there
a lot of nudity in True Blood a lot oh
my God it's literally porn
oh my God yeah and my grandma was like
nope
you know usually when I see like a
graphic uh movie or something and I'm
sitting with my parents or something you
just silently watch it yeah awkwardly
but I like that she takes the initiative
yeah even when they're kissing the
channel not even that that's good but
any TV show it's funny well she's dead
now but
sorry no it was in 2015. yeah it was
literally a long time ago uh Steven says
physically painful working with
non-creative people rather work in a
factory
and try to survive in a space as
soul-cushing as Corporate America I
think I would too Fame very well just a
button pushing Factory yeah if Ian's old
internship position is open okay here we
go I just moved to L.A and we'll move
mountains for an opportunity to be hd's
coffee boy
uh thank you Steve
I'd rather jump off a building honestly
I was just telling my friends that I
don't know what I would do if actually
Tick Tock got banned yes you got to be
scared about that I'm not that scared
I'm never scared to put anything because
I know life will work out for me as he
usually does which is
a crazy thing to say but it does
um but I don't think I can go back to
work in a normal job that's it but you
have a well you have a fan base you
figured it out yeah I'll figure out
something
I don't think it's gonna happen either I
think if anything they're just gonna
sell it because they like why would bite
dance want to turn down like billions of
dollars yeah over nothing I doubt it's
going to disappear as well it's too
important
it's important do you feel tick tock's
important yeah I do because it like it
keeps everybody
in contact with each other like it's a
very like
um Global it is and so many people are
on there I think I would say it's the
biggest app it is right now yeah it is I
think it has the most users yeah so it's
like why would you do away with
something like that that's dumb Tick
Tock is
I love Tick Tock and I'll tell you my
favorite thing is like I don't think
that you could have succeeded yeah doing
what you're doing anywhere else because
you have like they have all these
transient
people even if you're like a zero
follower account you're gonna put people
in your life yeah and it's so cool that
you have that chance I I also think the
same thing because I feel like I'm
thinking about like other apps that I
could possibly do what I do on and they
don't exist like Instagram live but
random people won't come in there yeah
it'll be the people that are in the live
yeah there's a app called Vigo where
it's kind of like you can talk to random
people the same way uh but like oh amigo
yeah but it's not the same as Tick Tock
that's Tick Tock is like it has the live
aspect and it also has like the feed
aspect the video aspect all the other
things too it's not just the live
uh what was your when did you basically
decide to make a tick tock how did that
all come about
um I think it was in 2020. it's just
like bored like everybody else coven era
and then like just made an account and
then started like posting on there
um I didn't start going live though
until like last year I think or maybe
2021 I mean 2023 right this is 20. yeah
I think I started doing it in 2021
possibly
like here and there and then I got more
serious last year
so what was the rise to in popularity
like because you what was your early you
know Tick Tock streams yeah early I
don't even remember honestly all of that
was like a blank I don't even know how I
started the last that's like very out of
my personality to do that I think I was
just like super tired of life because I
would go like I think I still worked at
Amazon at that time and I was working at
the other company
um and I would get off of work and be
like have so much like pent up like not
aggression but like just wanting to like
do something in an outlet looking for an
outlet and then I would just I think I
just like decided to just go live one
day like with a wig on and close and
just start talking to random people
that's kind of the crazy thing again
it's so special to still like I remember
the first time I went live on there
you're like what the [__] yeah this
thing's on yeah and you just started
talking to people and more people
started showing up yeah and it was like
from
uh 1K to 4K to 5K and then Doja cat and
then
yeah
well when did when did um the Terry Joe
and all the characters yeah
it's from the beginning
oh from the beginning yeah I've never
went live I only went live as myself
once really yeah so you start that's so
interesting where did these characters
come from then are they part of you like
before all this was this something you
were going with I think they just came
about like through like improv kind of
because like I had this like one uh one
year I was like an old lady for
Halloween and I had like this like old
lady dress on and I had like a random
wig in my house I just had random wigs
in my house I put the wig on put the
lady dress on and just went live and
then I wasn't even I don't think I was
talking in like a country accent until
like it just started happening like
gradually nothing was ever nothing ever
as a plan out thought planned out
thought for me just happens gradually
yeah
that's that's wow that's so crazy that
it was all from improv did you always
want to be like in comedy or improv or
anything like that I actually hate
comedy you hate comedy like you don't
like the genre I hate every single
comedy movie I hate stand up I I don't
enjoy it dude I gotta say
comedy as a genre the movies they're not
good yeah like they're not funny yeah
like the subject matter is good sure and
like I get where they're going with the
jokes but then like I think the jokes
are just like already
they're
just so like
what's the word corny no that but
they're they're expected yeah like you
know what they're gonna say you know
what the joke is going to be right so
it's like it's not really funny and I
like I literally physically get upset
when I if I go to a movie like a movie
theater and people are laughing at the
movie I'm like what's funny like I like
I don't find it funny at all so did you
want to be a comedian or make people
laugh that that's just coming a surprise
but you must have been like a funny
person I feel like I guess yeah yeah I
don't I don't well I was gonna say I
don't see myself as funny but I guess I
am yeah you're funny yeah funny looking
I'm just gonna you're fine no um I don't
know I think it's just like some people
have like a natural like thing about
them or you look at them and they're
just like you think they're funny like
you just look at them I think that's
what I do I wouldn't say I like make
jokes like I don't like not right not a
funny man yeah but you're funny because
I feel like comedians like they plan out
their jokes they make them and like it
makes sense but I don't ever plan on
anything it just happens
the same way bro yeah we're like I think
we're Kinder experienced yes
it won't be the first guy because
um but actually touching on something
you said that before Tick Tock you would
go home yeah and start streaming and um
that you life was really hard for you at
that point yeah I have a clip here I
want to play or well I don't have to
play it but please don't I will let it
create stuff well it's you saying that
basically
you had you were considering like
unaliving potentially right now but that
you wouldn't do it yeah but that that
you were expressing how was it from the
video where I was like drunk yeah you
were drunk
that video I cannot watch that video
actually because it like I see myself
and I look very like sad
yeah it looked like you were going
through a really hard time I think I
just hated working that's literally it I
felt like I feel like I felt like the
way most people feel where it's like you
just feel stuck you feel like stuck yeah
at your job you feel stuck in life and
it's just like it's a never-ending cycle
of like [__] you don't want to do
um
and then it changed yeah I would never
I
may say things about like like what you
just said not alive yeah I would never
do that yeah but you also mentioned that
it was like hard as a gay man and word
said that I think you did I never said
that in my life I think I think you did
say that I never said that ever oh he
you said you would never unalive
yourself because that's gay
and I'm not gay right okay
um but that's the job
um
no but I don't know I think that's sweet
I wouldn't say that's weird because
people obviously struggle with like
depression and things of that nature and
they don't have like
the choice to be like oh not going to do
that yeah that's obviously what they're
thinking in their brain but I personally
would never yeah I know well I wouldn't
say would never there's there's a road
where anything is possible that's how
inspiring yeah
anything is possible
um yeah you say in that video that you
were looking for purpose and you had no
idea what it was you feel like you found
it yeah
possible I mean a little bit yeah
I I wouldn't say I was looking for
purposely I don't think I said that
either I mean I made it like or what
what you said you were looking for uh
like I was saying like this can't be it
like this can't be life this can't be
all there is to offer life just driving
Amazon packages yeah literally yeah and
it wasn't it's not and if anybody out
there is feeling that way
it's not life has so much to offer
actually and for example uh True Blood
yeah that's always the only thing that
yeah I've always got vampire drama
um it's got to be like a nice Outlet
though because as Terry Joe yeah you get
to talk mad [__] yeah say all this crazy
wild stuff and character and then you
get to like step away from it yeah it's
kind of gonna do that in real life is
that cathartic if anybody knows me in
real life I do that to them as well
it's just like banter I feel like
growing up in a house
a black household especially with all
boys being
the gay fat one oh your brother's all
like yeah athletic yeah athletic
um just your typical African-American
male
um and then I'm like the complete
opposite okay I mean obviously I would
be the target of all those
um all the the jokes and the banter I
don't know I just feel like growing up
like that like I just like it kind of
like stuck with me and I just like
that's just how I play with everyone
like is it playful bad did you feel like
uh left out a little bit growing up
being like so different from everything
a little bit Yeah Yeah but I didn't
really care like I didn't want to hang
out with them like they were not like
interesting to me even to this day like
they know I don't really like you guys
aren't super close
um no not really me and my little
brother are the closest
and are the other brothers close
like with each other yeah with each
other yeah like I think they hang out
almost every day wow I just I don't see
what I would be they go play like
basketball and stuff I'm like I'm not
playing basketball okay
and put a wig on and go live so so when
you were a kid because you were like a
middle child so what they would go and
do Sports and stuff and what would you
do in the house watching that So Raven
That's So Raven yeah you watch it by
yourself nobody wanted to watch So Raven
no everyone would just be out doing
whatever they're doing and I'll be in
the house eating hot pockets that's
what's up that sounds like a good ass
time yeah and then my mom would be like
get out of the house go do something and
then you were the one that actually uh
got a cool ass job yeah so what now so
Raven exactly
That's So Raven I don't know anything
about that yeah I love Raven cool Raven
is that her name Raven Symone I don't
know That's So Raven what does that even
mean it's a TV show but her name was
Raven yeah and That's So Raven yeah yeah
That's So Raven I actually know some of
my favorite TV shows growing up I also
think that's like kind of where I get
like the
the character thing from because oh she
can see the future yeah oh that is so
Raven That's cool let's see what I would
be doing like very wacky things like
getting into like different characters
and like just doing stuff I think that's
also like a little inspiration of what I
do
nice
so growing up there in that house you
seems like you were just a little bit of
an outsider
you guys would sit would you guys like
sit at dinner as a family no never you
guys ever come together as a family
never know well except for like how how
was Halloween oh Thanksgiving you're
like oh yeah you guys all come together
otherwise not really no really yeah so
what does everyone do for dinner
do separate things like when you're a
kid yeah when you're a kid I mean like
Mom was like just growing up yeah she
would just make food and we would just
you just grab it separately yeah
my mom would ever I dreamed of that yeah
but my mom I don't think she would ever
let me have that freedom or you'd like
just we would literally eat in our rooms
we would not have to say dude my parents
would kill me if I tried that and I
wouldn't wish I could do that yeah mom
didn't really care she's like whatever
just do whatever did you guys were you
guys able to grab food and just bail
Olivia says yes
I think it's you guys are a little
younger than me I think back in the day
parents just were like I will [__]
kill you yeah mine were looking at this
table you don't sit at this goddamn
table yeah I don't know my mom also had
us like very young so she was young as
like having like four kids so it's like
she was like doing her own thing that's
hard four kids man how old was she when
she had the your oldest sibling I think
she was like 16. bro yeah so your mom's
kind of a hero a hero well I don't know
wait raising four boys for sure from 16
watches and be like oh dude that that is
that's an achievement to come out of
that like a live on the other side sure
yeah that's I that's a feat it is I have
two boys yeah and I have tons of help
and they are like a freaking tornado
every night like a goddamn category five
hurricane I hate children
I just feel like they're very loud and
they are they don't they're messy yeah
they don't listen I don't have time for
them I don't have like the mental
capacity that's what's up and you know
that about yourself so good my cousin
gets so mad because she has kids and
she's like can you watch them like hell
no that you did that that's your best
funny
unless you want like really needed me to
then I would so you guys would all go
your separate rooms oh we literally I'll
share the room you guys all shared a
room how can you share a room and not be
close
because I was The Outsider they were
close the four boys in one room what was
that set up two bunk beds two bunk beds
yeah like category
oh [__] yeah that's crowded bedroom yeah
it was all right it wasn't that bad yeah
you kind of enjoy it when you're little
because it's like it's just like having
like your friends Allah is with you yeah
yeah even though I didn't really like
them but top bunkers bottom bunk I don't
know I don't remember you know yeah
oh and was the bathroom situation like
four boys
and that specific house where we're like
in the same room there was only one
bedroom it was an apartment okay two
bedrooms one bath look at this what's
that chaos mom as well oh [__] yeah I
hated it oh my God
everywhere you can just piss everywhere
right that's the boy thing just piss
yeah everywhere just everything
everywhere because I don't think we
really well that's getting too far into
it
go ahead I know
uh oh I know and like uh let's say shout
the shower drain never works properly I
don't we don't have hair no no not from
here
oh well we're all like very young yeah
yeah
we're all like four oh my God no not
when you're four no whenever like we
lived in the same room really okay okay
my oldest brother's only four years
older than me damn you guys are real
tight yeah is it four yeah he's only
four years older than me the other one's
other other one is two years older than
me and my little brother is busy as hell
during those yeah four years yeah
and as you said you have a stepdad
where's your dad yeah where's my real
one is he involved sorry
huh is your what's the story with your
biological dad I think I'm only met him
like once
I don't even know what he looks like to
be honest yeah I would see the father of
all for you no oh just two okay and then
the other two have different dads I
wouldn't even
um
consider him my dad I consider my
stepdad my dad I don't even call him my
stepdad you call him Dad yeah well I
call him by his name
but you think of him yeah and how long
has he been in your life this is also in
the elementary oh yeah interesting
that's like I think fifth grade maybe no
earlier than that like first grade and
do they have kids together no so he dude
he's also like a hero is he all your
brothers kind of accept him as Dad yeah
he's been in our lives since well that's
something that show's right that's
awesome yeah good guy we I have a step
sister as well because he had like a
daughter before
so what what's what what did your
clearly he was very young when your mom
got pregnant I'm assuming who your dad
your biological dad yeah I'm sure
so what's the story did he just like
fail you don't even know really I mean
you're not seriously yeah because I
don't really care honestly I don't care
about people who I don't know
like if you're not serious at all I'd be
like okay is he alive do you know that
yeah he's alive he's alive I would
assume is he in Texas
does he know about your like success he
doesn't live that far from you no
I don't know I don't keep in contact
with any part of the FM that part of my
family like at all
I don't know I I find that that doubt I
would
I think what you're I would find that so
hurtful that my dad was there and he
didn't care biological dad
I feel like it's just like I've even
like I don't believe in like family ties
in that way I feel like your family is
who you making it who you make it it's
not like your blood it really if you're
like blood related to somebody it
doesn't really mean anything they can be
a horrible person like that doesn't mean
you have to like love them right
um like even like if my mother was a
horrible person I would not talk to her
I wouldn't care about her I wouldn't
care but she's not she's not nah yeah I
just don't care about like blood
relation that means nothing to me is
that influence from your love of True
Blood or is that just something no
I don't know anything about that Joe no
like a person thing like I feel like if
you can't care if somebody doesn't care
about you why should you care about them
well that's great if you can actually
like yeah feel that you know yeah
but is he aware of your success has he
tried to reach out to you interesting
no yeah I would be like who is this
honestly who is that though because I
don't even know what he looks like
what about your brothers do they they
don't care they don't care no wow my
oldest brother is like in contact with
his dad and my youngest brother's dad
died so so he's just your dad none of
your brothers have him as me and the one
that's two years older than me okay yeah
I don't know how a guy does that he had
two kids with your mom she doesn't care
yeah and then he just bailed I don't
know how someone does that yeah it's
done quite often actually which is very
strong I don't get it yeah
like I just don't get it I mean that's a
good thing that you don't get it because
you can't relate to
that kind of like that person that kind
of person
does he play Child Support I'm sure he's
got really right well not now because
we're all adults yeah but if he okay so
then do something I don't know I never
asked you know you don't you don't ask
about that
hmm I'd love to talk to your mom if
she's available right now yeah
uh wow
should we get her on the podcast it
sounds rough but uh you seem like you
did okay with it all
I don't really um process
rough situation you don't process trauma
no just let it go yeah I just feel like
there's no reason there's no reason to
like dwell on like negative things it's
like
I think you're just living your life
negatively it's time for that just let
it go God bless which is not that easy
for everyone but no it's not but if you
could do it God bless yeah and so what
was uh the school situation like you
went to school in the same place in
Houston
and like my most of my life I've always
lived in like the same areas and also my
mom sisters
and my cousins would also like every
time we would move they would move with
us oh okay we would all like move into
the same apartment so we like live near
each other all the time so it's like
having like built-in best friends all
the time just like everywhere around you
so they're close with uh your mom's side
oh that's that's interesting my mom said
it's very close
we see each other almost every day
almost and what was school like growing
up like uh with your friends normal
um
growing up obviously it's like like
being gay or gay-ish
um it's like people always like ask you
like are you gay are you gay are you gay
in elementary I didn't even know what
gay was before everyone was telling me
that I was gay they were asking before I
even knew what it was yeah or they were
calling me they I was like you're gay
I'm like okay you were giving off today
in elementary school currently wow I
don't know they're just like you're gay
and it was like I don't even know what
that means but okay but I could tell
that it was like something like negative
because like by the way they're saying
it so I'm just like okay
um and then Middle School comes along
and then you start to know more things
you're like oh and then people are
asking me and I'm like no
well I'm like what do you think because
I'm like you're gonna think what you
want to think stop asking me dumb
questions like do you think I'm gay if
you think so then I might be oh you know
you were gay at the an early age yeah
yeah well when I knew what it was when
you figured out yeah because I'm just
like well this makes sense but I don't I
never saw like the the big deal about it
I think people make sexuality such a big
deal when it's really not it's just what
you're sexually attracted to yeah which
means like literally nothing to anyone
and was your family super accepting of
all that
[Music]
um
growing up with Brothers obviously
they're gonna be like
they gave you a hard time yeah but like
not that I cared like they would be like
calling me like the F slur really yeah
could they get over that now yeah they
don't say that to you now that'd be wild
yeah but that's like it's it's it's
[Music]
um
assumed for like young boys to be like
very homophobic or like yeah just weird
in general yeah um so I never really
cared
um but I never really got like that in
school just the question yeah
do you feel like
like when did you come out of the closet
never we're still in the closet I'm not
in the closet I was never in the closet
apparently you were just being yourself
the whole time exactly I don't I don't
like the notion of coming out of the
closet so I'm like what why would I do
that you were always genuine I don't
think anybody should do that because
like just be yourself why do why should
I say people have to come out and like
announce that they're gay when people
don't do that well like no I mean
theoretically in a perfect world that's
yeah right right but some people's
families are like they grow up with like
I hate gay people yeah people are going
to hell it's like how do you tell your
mom yeah tell her just be like you're a
don't tell her at all because it doesn't
matter what is she gonna do kill you you
have an interesting theory on things
yeah I just think that people a lot of
people I understand the pressure
obviously but I think people like feel
pressure from their family members to do
things or to say things or to be a
certain way but like I just feel like
why do you care like obviously they're
your family but you have to live your
life for you you can't live
you're a life for somebody else that's
dumb or it's like I want to say dumb but
it's just something you shouldn't be
doing
it's counterproductive yeah because like
when they die who are you right
who are you going to be you should just
be that your answer because you're
miserable you have to be miserable like
living your life pretending to be
someone you're not which I me on life to
be someone I'm not
um I don't know
do if you if you had a significant other
would you like bring him home to meet
your family oh yeah
um and not I don't know yeah I would I
wouldn't care yeah
um I just don't I don't see that
in the near future you don't see yeah
yeah interesting only because I really
don't like date like that you don't date
yeah no you never had have you had a
boyfriend
yeah you've had a boyfriend very
recently though oh are you dating right
now are you do you have a significant
other right now no
you thought about that for a minute it's
complicated okay yeah okay yeah it's
really complicated but I so your first
serious relationship is happening
potentially yeah
you you don't want to say that because
if he sees this you might be embarrassed
is that one no okay
I don't know
it's just complicated okay yeah
interesting
this is very complicated actually
well okay fantastic yeah
um
I'm surprised that voice hasn't came out
yet I'm trying so hard not to
so do you have any idea kind of uh
you have a vision for where you want to
be in like 10 years no I don't like to
think that far into the future because I
could be dead tomorrow
um which is also not a good like thing
to be like
because I want to actually plan out my
life but also I just like to live in the
now hmm you have a business email people
reach out to you yeah actually just put
my email in my bio
because I just know I feel like this out
loud you don't say it out loud no but oh
yeah yeah I know what you mean yeah yeah
but I have a feeling people are going to
be trying to contact you yeah because
you have this unique incredible
thing that you're doing and I think
I think you are the moment yeah do you
know what I mean yeah Terry Joe is
happening right now yeah and forever I'm
just kidding forever she dies
um I don't know I I literally have no
clue what I'm doing I'm just doing it
right just winging and just winging
everything you have like something
respect right here yeah thanks bro how
long was that there no I would have told
you but I just noticed that
yeah you know it's hard because I know
what you mean when I first started out
it's like I'm having fun this is good I
don't want to think about it and there
was a point where
I was like wait I should be taking this
more seriously because like you said I
don't want to be in the position where I
have to go back to work yeah God I would
die right like it's horrible a horrible
thought God forbid
everybody at home watching from work
yeah sorry idiots
we love you guys we love the
proletariators yeah we need them
yeah but uh I would think like okay I
need to make sure that I seize this
opportunity right now and so doing stuff
like I saw you make some merch and she
did that cool ass vampire promo yeah
that was good
um it's so funny because when I do those
things I don't think them through I just
like set up the camera and just do
whatever I love that video yeah the
vampire one
um I that video was like filmed so like
impromptu it's so funny yeah
but something else I guess I would think
about is like
I think what you're doing now is awesome
that you came on the podcast I think
that's good yeah have you had more
opportunities like that or no this is
the first time I've been asked to be on
a podcast well yeah I think it is that's
crazy I'm so glad we were the first ones
it was my first time ever being on one
well there's uh how many people are
watching right now three million forty
five thousand hold on let me just hit 36
000. yeah yeah
uh people are some people are saying
they're unemployed good for you okay
period literally me figure it out 2020.
yeah yeah
um
yeah so I don't know at some point I do
think it'd be good to start thinking
like more strategic about like going on
shows but I guess nobody invited you for
some a dumb ass reason
well not yet I'm sure they will they're
coming yeah Ellen I'm coming she's gone
who's that who's Ellen now she's dead
damn yeah you would be perfect for Ellen
what do you mean I don't know like the
show yeah yeah yeah yeah or like being
the host of Ellen
I think would you do that a variety show
um
yeah I think that'd be good for you yeah
actually I have no clue I don't know
what I can do until I do it like I
didn't know I was gonna do this I didn't
know how I was gonna do this I never
plan or prepare for anything I just Wing
everything Wendy Williams is retiring
yeah she has to can we step up to that
maybe
oh well I don't think I want to be hated
I feel like she's hated and loved at the
same time I hate both hate and love her
yeah I don't know that was her oh that
is her
yeah we have a lot of Wendy Williams
down but that's her farting where to God
not her I swear to God never we isolated
it turned up the game I don't think so
dude I swear to her swear to God that's
the whole thing that's her that came
straight from her yeah um I hope she's
doing well yeah he's she's a queen she
goes Wendy I saw a video of her she's
like I would ask for your privacy but I
would never respect anyone's privacy
that's the Monday Hot Topic yeah I was
like okay girl
people put their um lives out there the
public people I mean that doesn't give
them people the right to talk about it
but
are you putting yourself out there right
now yeah how do you feel about that
because you're super private I don't
know if it's from design but like it's
hard to find anything about you yeah
like me yeah about you yeah because I
don't I just don't post anything about
me
because I'm not that interesting I don't
think I'm that interesting of a person
aside from like the
The Tick Tock stuff so I don't do
anything I literally sit at my house and
do nothing all the time
yeah how do you social media that yeah I
have that problem too I mean last
weekend was crazy
because my cousin's car got stolen from
my house oh [__] yeah and then we went
to go like find her car
um I also met Lana's ex last weekend you
did yeah how'd that come about Houston
he was in Houston for like
um
what something oh he was in Houston for
like a little concert yeah and then
um we went out to clubs with my friend's
um birthday that night
and then we were leaving the club
because it was kind of boring and then
we saw like two Escalades pull up and
then people were like oh my God this
little nonsense like pulling up in
Escalade to go to the club I guess he
for sure knows who you are yeah and um I
started waving into the car and then
like one of the dancers like recognized
me and then they like stopped the car
and then I ran over there and then like
hugged him and the dancers and then I
was like where you guys going and
they're going to the club we just left I
was like oh we're going back did you
hang out with me yeah oh fun it was cool
it was fun
he seems nice that's why whenever you
pull the picture off yeah
no he is really nice he seems cool I've
been a fan of his yeah
they're really fun to have um to like
party with I almost said have sex with
you
yeah well hit me up I'm just kidding but
um tell me about the car a car got
stolen from your house yeah apparently I
don't know they're saying there's like a
tick tock turn people stealing Kias or
like [__] Hyundai's wait I've heard
about that there's like a specific car
that's easy yeah like hot wire because
they're like I don't know how they're
doing but they're like like ripping out
the bottom of your um
steering wheel and then like using a USB
to like start the car what the yuck I
have no clue and we thought her car got
towed can you pull up one of those I
want to watch one of those a video
someone stealing yeah why not
um and without her car got told that we
saw like
glass on the floor like I might have
someone steal your car so we call the
police and then they literally came we
weren't even we're a little drunk so
like um when the police came they're
like using their flashlight and then we
they literally saw my cousin's like home
like window like off to the side we
didn't even notice it
um and the next morning we found a car
though so oh you got it back yeah so
what did they do with the car
they literally just drove it around like
joyriding they went to a mall stealing a
car just for a laugh yeah and now you're
in jail that seems like a really yeah
expensive dummy yeah but you got it back
and it was fine yeah well they
definitely went on a high-speed chase
and there's a couple of dings here and
there and her whole alignment was off
but we're gonna get fixed so it doesn't
matter what the hell well I'm glad she
got her car back yeah Los Angeles
officials say the viral trend has led to
an 85 increase in car theft of Hyundai's
and Kias compared with lots
how do you say it
oh it's your Sunday well why they got
the Y in there I have no clue Hyundai
how do the Japanese say it no clue
oh [__]
I'm not okay I know the difference yeah
people trust me and she has a high Union
forever
you actually listen to K-pop I love
K-pop I love everything name one BTS
song
butter
that is actually a song I Know Name
another uh
diet
Dynamite
you're cheating Dynamite yeah okay we
stand K-pop in this household same I
would I just love them I love South
Korea I would never go against the
family like that I'm scared of them
oh um you should be actually I know that
fan base I've crossed them once and they
almost they've ruined me they ruined me
them the barbs with the barbs which ones
are those the Nicki Minaj okay Nicki
Minaj is the barbs they're they they're
passionate should never ever cross them
see I didn't know cardi B had that kind
of fandom she doesn't
they're mortal enemies yeah okay so
they're coming for me yeah we love Nicki
Minaj everyone's coming for you we love
wait this whole thing is about to get
shut down
outside right now okay done so then
Nicki Minaj is the barbs why are they
the barbs
um because that's just yeah like she
calls herself a Barbie oh she's a Barbie
because she's beautiful and perfect yeah
I agree
true I'm saying
whatever they say I agree you don't seem
like it no I'm on board okay I'm a Barb
name one I'm a Ken name a Nicki Minaj
song okay Nicki Minaj song uh dot
popcorn popcorn okay I never heard that
one Super Bass okay spaceships
space in the Trap okay cool who's
texting you that I'm Barb good notes
Here
barbs we love barbs same so wait you're
saying that we got Anaconda yeah
that's my favorite one name the lyrics
well you know I just I'm more of a
Melody guy okay cool yeah yeah I just
let's hear reality
it's the big butt sample a big anacondas
no that's not gonna go
guns and wigs my anaconda don't my
anaconda don't want none unless you've
got buns hun a boy tell your name Troy
used to live in Detroit
yeah that's it
that's it right there I'm a Barb now
you're a barber so wait the barbs are
the the menages the menages the Nicki
Minaj yes they're her fan base yes
and so what was the other one you were
saying the Beehive The Beehive is who oh
Beyonce
okay we love and nobody would disrespect
Beyonce ever in your life for any reason
yeah
or else you'll die I would never dude
that's the craziest one the gold is
almost the go against Beyonce is like
Cherry Mike Terry has yeah Aries yeah he
makes all the wrong choices
um
let's go to the beach each let's go get
a wave yeah
they say what they're gonna say I have a
drink clink on the bubbling but like not
sure okay so but why does
why does Nicki Minaj have this
Army so to speak
and yet cardi B doesn't have an army she
does she does she's not as powerful yeah
I'm sure she has a lot can I can I if I
say cardi B sucks is that gonna help me
um for the barbs yeah yeah you have to
worry about the party gang we hate her
yeah because they're coming for you
no but uh yeah I think that's her fan
base the party gang the bar D gang yeah
cardi B does your uh fan base have a
name
uh I think so yeah I would like to think
so
um
the god Warriors the god Warriors that's
what or the homosexuals either one wait
I haven't like officially
gave them one wait I I swear I've seen
you say
uh something else but you you don't have
official one no no I haven't officially
gave them like a fan base name the
Divine divine
the Divine the children of God no
everyone's a child of God Crusaders
no that's funny it was just like God
Warriors God Warrior one God Warriors
and so if you have this theoretical fan
base we want them to
uh
do we want them to ruin people's lives
like the other ones no no well if they
need to if they need to they go out yeah
the paladins
Paladin I don't even know what that
means honestly not that good
well
um
let's see here
are you doing anything in La what do you
have any plans out here
um I don't know actually I'm probably
gonna be like partying after this
because I don't have any like
um official things that I need to be
done yeah Frontier yeah nice nice a
couple
oh I wanted to say so like Doja cat did
she would you say she gave you like your
big break in a way a little bit yeah I
would say that like people got and
gained interest in me after she started
going live with me because they're like
who is this person and why is she going
live with him her they whatever
um so I would say so yeah
Dojo cat is so she's like such a tick
talker and I love that she's so
she's like so LinkedIn with internet
culture yeah I think it's awesome I like
her I love this generation yeah totally
yeah but you had a call with Madonna
where you guys did whip-its or what you
did but she did whip-its is that what
it's called people call it I guess the
pop oh it's the same thing though right
I guess is whip it a puppet uh no a
popular oh it's not so wait what did she
do because she had like a little proper
medical vial like what the hell was that
that's poppers typically used by gay men
during sexual activity or what to loosen
their anus wait it does that well it's
like like a muscle relaxer yeah
wait okay so I thought these people were
doing whippets the whole time that would
be pretty wild so wait
so okay well here's Madonna so I didn't
know what she was doing I love how
youthful Madonna is you know she's like
I'm doing the pit I'm doing the whip it
yeah you got the grills yeah poppers I
love her
okay and so when you're when you're on
this I'm not asking because I think you
know but if you do let me know what when
people do um
Hoppers do they usually have a medical
looking vial like Ladonna has that's
what it usually comes in yeah oh really
so here let's watch Madonna do a Opera
this blew my [__] mind she's so wild
dude
I look so different
yeah but anyways what are you getting
ready for where are you going
did you feel so wild for that
he is so wild for that
and you can see her like struggling to
keep it together so so what do you feel
when you do that is she like because I I
don't know what that drug is it why does
anyone done oh you did it once yeah I
was at the club one of my friends and
him he and this other boy I guess
they're probably gonna be doing some gay
stuff that night and he bought poppers
um he was like do you want to sniff it I
was like no I was like yeah and then I
just like snipped in and I was like it
just like gives you like a head brush
for like a minute or two are you sure
poppers and the whippets weapons aren't
the same thing down
a thousand percent sure because that's
what okay I'm not going to push on this
my old ass is just gonna be quiet I have
no clue what a Whip It is Well people
used to get like CO2 cartridges and
inhale it right Dan
yeah I know if it's CO2 but they would
like sniff the whipped creams yeah yeah
gas
that's what we used to get up to when I
was kids I don't know what all you
ngin oh we still do it Olivia whippets
are definitely still a thing it's just
they're not the same thing as possible
can you do it but one in each nostril if
you really want to go for it is that
racially motivated
no
okay
are you all right I'm a Christian
whoa
everything yep
she's feeling it well you know what I
usually almost sniff one of those
I'm sorry dude so you're connecting with
all these celebrities though it's so
it's so cool yeah that's got to feel
pretty amazing you've had Madonna Doja
cat Hunter Schaefer Trisha Paytas
whoever that is
Baby James Charles
baby Tate baby T Tate baby Tate yeah
what's baby Tate she's a rapper oh baby
take called in yeah
are you did you ever become like friends
with any of these people of them you
talk that's awesome I know I'm just
kidding
um I don't know I don't know what it is
where they come from or how they come to
me but lizzo do wedded you yeah she
hasn't followed me back yet though come
on lizzo yeah but I know she knows who I
am because she talks about me sometimes
see this is so interesting there it's
it's the stay it's marinating yeah it's
happening that's what's happening you're
on the cusp I think yeah yeah because of
what though I don't know insanity
maybe I think I've already greatness
greatness yeah
whippets is gas is usually sucked out of
a balloon
that's helium now yeah so you fill it up
with what
nitrous oxide that's the CO2 can right
it's not CO2 it's nitrous oxide so what
the [__] have I been sniffing you have
just I don't know I'm pretty sure too
much CO2 because I swear so that might
explain why I've just been huffing The
Leftovers of my goddamn whipped cream
can
you guys ever hear that one about you
could you could put banana rinds in the
oven and they get you high if you smoke
it no bro we were desperate times
brother did you try it I know I was
never that sad but I have friends who
they were straight up they had that
barbecue Ryan cooking that you can make
I heard this if you like ingest enough
nutmeg you could also give you like
man yeah I think it's not enough
probably don't do that we should say
don't do that oh no yeah that's not real
yeah all that stuff
do not smoke a fat bowl of nutmeg
whatever you do
I'll be smoking I think you just eat it
you just eat it yeah but I do that
people do that all the time like not a
large amounts
wait you can nut Meg overdose apparently
you can die from eating too much nutmeg
so you ride that as close as you can
yeah it's probably just you being on the
verge of death that's where the hike
that's exhilarating so if you want to
die then do it but if you don't no no we
don't don't do it at all no nutmeg
overdoses please yeah she's also died
nutmeg May produce symptoms similar to
those of an anti
cholinogenic poisoning
the reported initial neurological
effects include gettiness tingling
euphoria
and hallucinations that may include
distortions of time and space I must
just be a nutmeg all the time then
because I feel all those symptoms dude
Detachment from reality sensations of
separation from one's Limb and fear of
impending death well that seems like
that fear is warranted this is often
that big right what this is often nutmeg
this is all from nutmeg dude I wonder
how much don't tell us the audience
doesn't mean what's the what's the
recreational dosage of nutmeg
oh that's crazy I smoke crack once that
was the crazy oh my God just one time
never I think the craziest thing I've
ever done was poppers
poppers yeah that's the craziest you
never [__] around with no just Weed
and Alcohol
but I don't like smoking weeds MDMA or
acid nutmeg banana peels no nutmeg it
sounds like nutmeg is like the hardest
drug on the whipped cream none of that
okay you're a good boy yes are you
curious are you just not you don't care
I just feel like I would die I feel like
I would accidentally like jump off a
bridge oh I did anything yeah like yeah
then don't rather not yeah not that good
yeah it's overrated
um
as little as two teaspoons or five grams
are you gonna try it tonight aren't you
how much can I get a visual
representation of how much nutmeg is
five grams you gotta crunch that [__]
down like
what the [__] this is this is news to me
this is granulated now
it's already granulated
I have no clue dude this is crazy this
is blowing my mind about nutmeg you at
the grocery store
no I'm just speaking I love cookies
eggnog tonight
no wonder people like nutmeg so much
actually I hate it too yeah gross nasty
well um who's your the favorite
celebrity I think you've had who's
called in yeah
I'm gonna say does cat yeah she's
awesome she's cool I like her and
there's got to be a certain like it's
just so cool that she was the first one
yeah so I was like shook whenever
they're like oh that was your class
wants to join your life those guys want
to join your life shut up no she doesn't
and I looked in the guest questions
she's like actually there and I'm like
oh my God how and then I just add her
but then I'm like I don't want to be
like oh my God
like whatever you stayed in character
which is good here I actually pulled it
out I don't know if this is the first
time how you've talked to her a lot of
times Dojo yeah she's a regular
not anymore she doesn't go live anymore
oh she had like I think she had like a
social media
love
it's called
um
apparently at least my wig don't look
like it's coughing it's how they don't
know how like oh that's my other account
that's why though dude you have so
psionic three yeah I'm gonna have eight
accounts you have such an operation
going on yeah it's like I keep getting
banned so I have to go from one account
to the next and you're you're protecting
the main one yeah how do you keep the
main one from getting banned it depends
all the time every time I go live it
gets bad but then they unban you yeah
when I appeal it you peel it and they
like it back sometimes not all the time
you've been bad for a long time on your
main accounts for a week a week yeah
it's not too bad that's the longer I
think that's the longest anybody's ever
banned hmm
really no I we got permanently banned
like permanently oh I've got permanently
bad before too but when you appeal it
they well when I we couldn't even log in
yeah it was just like [__] you that's
happened to me a couple times too they
logged me out they're like your whole
account is here yeah and then I just
appeal it you love a person I do have a
tick tock like manager that's good
manager you got uh a manager so that's
good that's exact Live manager just
someone who works at Tick Tock yeah so
if you get banned they can help you
right yeah you got banned for a week Amy
what'd you do honestly I don't recall I
just remember it being [__] and I
couldn't get in touch with anyone I
tried reaching out and I just had to
wait the week out yeah it was a long
time ago it was before I worked here
they'd just be handing out bands man
as they said yeah fan every degenerate
[__] the losers Hunter Schaefer called
in that was really cool love her too has
she called in more than once it took
like three times
I have about that's awesome she's cute
I'm huge yeah that's true physically
what do you want
you cure her over here
I look so different about these clips
dude you look awesome there it's awesome
I love when you show the cleavage
everyone always people actually think
I'm a girl like you really pull the look
of it's really I think it's the tits and
also I like like put on when I go on
Tick Tock live I um put all the filters
like all the way up like right smoothing
the hair right and the hair the
smoothing the eyes and the jaw right
make everything look as feminine as
possible yeah
so she's trying to bait poor Terry go
into admitting something Unholy
I don't know what you're talking about I
like everything about me on the line
yeah so that was awesome yeah yeah and
now you've met me so yeah
not nearly as famous as all this yeah
that's awesome so just as famous we're
all famous I think um
I'm so happy for you yeah you've done
awesome I think you're super talented
yeah and I'm sure it's gonna keep on
going I really do I think it's all it's
just crazy what you've achieved and
there's like this Mystique I'm serious
like yeah so this is really cool I'm
glad we could talk and learn a little
bit about we really enjoyed this I
didn't
think it was going to be like this fun
and it's cool oh nice but I actually
really enjoyed this oh thank you I did
too yeah is there anything you want to
say anything you want people to know
um I'm pregnant
and I'm due tomorrow
no I don't know
um this was fun I really enjoyed this
um
I never really have anything to say to
be honest yeah yeah
I feel that I'm just a very quiet person
well we talking this entire time no yeah
I think you did awesome and I'm it's
awesome to get to know you but uh
uh
yeah let's stay in touch I want to help
you with the get on YouTube and stuff or
I have a YouTube reps too who can help
you like convert your Tick Tock uh
content there was that other guy Garrett
uh whatever fish and Garrett he also is
like this huge tick Tucker yeah who's
trying to move to YouTube and I had
someone from YouTube reach out they're
like hey connect us so I can help so I
don't know maybe that could be good for
you yeah I don't know I started posting
on YouTube like little Vlogs here and
there but I haven't been like taking it
seriously here let me promote it so
people can go subscribe oh here it is
you guys can watch this drunken
confession oh my God that video like
kills me
well it's still up you want to watch it
oh no
it's funny though but like that's the
official one this is the official it's
one that you control or I'll put it I'll
put a link to it in the description
yeah you put everything put the toilet I
have the tick tock I have your main Tick
Tock in there but I'll die on the
YouTube
for me
like I hate it like I really want to die
[Laughter]
off of like like Walmart wine oh yeah
I've been there yeah that box and my
apartment sweating and like just drunk
or something but it's funny though
like I connect
oh my God
where were you then in your life like
what do you what do you feel when you
see that
no I just feel like I two years ago yeah
I was just like
living which one I'm doing which is what
I'm doing now but I I feel like it's
more
I have more of a purpose since we're
talking about purposes I have more of
purpose now than I did then then I just
felt like I was like
aimlessly driving a car for eight hours
a day and then coming home and eating
nachos
clip of the nachos going down because I
saw that I was like okay yeah
hard to tell because of the lighting the
lighting I just literally had like those
strip LED lights on my wall kind of a
Vibe though the lighter you went past it
I think I just saw a plate
where's them nachos at
Baltimore that's how crazy that [__] he
is
I don't even live in Baltimore huh
girl that's
crazy sometimes I watch videos of myself
and I'm like what is that that's what
I'm saying like I'm like this is a funny
guy right here yeah
I'm I'm like a very strange person
because I feel like I'm like 18
different people
because I look at that and I'm like who
is that really yeah but when you get
drunk in general do you come out like
this or is this just a different thing
yeah I think so yeah
but I have to go
that's gay that's real good
[Music]
oh my god did you edit this yeah you put
in some special effects some jump cuts
that was good I did all of that from
like iMovie that's good man whatever I
guess I gotta go but that's why I'm
trying to get um
got some sound effects going on there I
love that because like it's giving
YouTube like I can do YouTube like I can
stay here
sit here and drinks
no you go for that chip I've seen this
video I've seen this video yeah yeah
yeah all right oh my God
yeah a girl was hungry because I did the
whole vibe of this video is so wild with
the lighting yeah sweating this sweating
the lights I was talking about repeating
the same thing over and over oh this is
this is the restroom door open
disgusted the living room being empty
have you ever had this moment and
working where you're like maybe this is
my whole life and I'm just gonna have to
I have to learn yeah I'm gonna have to
accept this that this is my whole life
yeah I'm gonna be this guy who drives
this car
I don't know I I've never felt like that
because I just know that wasn't for me
it was where I was but I knew it wasn't
where I was gonna be forever that's nice
yeah I started I was five years at a
desk job when I started to feel like
this might be it yeah
I would like to actually die
I couldn't I don't know how they do it
man yeah well I don't think it's that I
don't think it's it for them either I
don't think well it is like do for a lot
of people well I feel like this because
like it's like I wonder if you're always
moving around yeah
I think that was the way of life for
like older Generations but nowadays I
don't think people are this generation
are accepting that I think they're
trying to find different Avenues of
things to actually that make them happy
to do what they want to do and actually
like be able to make a living off
yeah it's true there's a lot more
different ways to live yeah we're just
not going for it anymore that's it we're
not gonna put up with this [__] yeah any
goddamn longer people doing it
still doing it
um no I don't think so I think I think
um as the years go on there would be
like a shift where it's like people are
actually excited to do the things they
want to do because it's something they
actually enjoy
this is the word question when you were
a kid
did you always have this sense that like
I don't know how to describe it like
that you were
special you are best at yeah destined to
do be different or do something
different or to be more than like just a
worker or something if you ask my
family there they would tell you that
every since I was kind of I would be
like I'm gonna be famous I'm Gonna Be
Rich I'm gonna live in California which
I don't want to do anymore as an adult
because you don't want to talk about
finances
um yeah you'll be rich You're Gonna Be
Rich yeah hopefully
um but they would I would always be like
Oh I'm Gonna Be Rich I'm gonna be living
in California I'm gonna be like an actor
or whatever
um
so I think I've always like had that in
the back of my head
so that's why I was gonna I never felt
like I was gonna be like stuck stuck
doing something interesting
you feel like you manifested it or you
feeling that um
just talking about being open to the
world right
I heard Bob Dylan described that once
yeah he said
it's on video maybe you guys can find it
I always thought it was really
interesting because I felt that too a
little bit I know I I hate saying it
because it sounds so
but what he said was really good he goes
I had this dream
that I was going to be the famous
musician whatever and but it was such a
soft fragile dream that if he spoke it
to anyone it would blow away yeah like
it was such a dim light in the back of
his head that uh
does that make sense yeah it makes a lot
of sense yeah I always thought that was
really interesting way to speak
existence and like it feels like
things are gonna like
take that dream away from you right but
I feel like if it's meant for you it's
meant for you and if it's not it's not
and that's okay as well
I don't know
I think the universe has its way of
making things
happen when it's supposed to yeah
there it is
that's why I never Force anything
everything I do is like organic it just
happens naturally that's a that's a good
way to do it it's worked out yeah so far
we'll see just don't smoke too much
nutmeg yeah I might use to not actually
let's go into politics
you'll find me at Publix tonight yo can
I get a shot glass of nutmeg
and they're like no it becomes illegal
nuts oh he said that's my mom he he said
it's a thing kind of thing
he's obviously more eloquent than me the
kind of thing that you have to keep to
your own self because it's a fragile
feeling
and you put it out there somebody will
kill it yeah so it's best to keep that
all inside
I love that I agree but also me
personally I never cared you don't care
no that's good I love it like you're
never been to them like yeah sure
I won't
and then I do is there anyone from your
previous life that's like hey dude
what's going on now no nobody no I
talked to everybody that I
talk to everybody that I talk to now are
people that I've known forever wow yeah
that's great
listen uh uh all right I'm not gonna I'm
Gonna Let You Go now thank God we did it
we did it for a long time yeah I mean I
could keep it going for like a long time
honestly no I'll tell you how long how
long two and a half hours yeah it
doesn't even feel like that long it
feels like literally 30 minutes that's
good yeah well um like I said I wish the
best and I'm so thankful that you came
and did this with us so I really
appreciate it and uh we're all huge fans
thank you also a fan of you guys oh
thank you and I um I'm very appreciative
of you even having me on the show oh it
was genuinely our pleasure I won I was
like I wonder he must not do interviews
because we've never seen him like that
we're like let's try to reach out and
see and uh we're all so stoked yeah and
here I am idiots all these idiots out
there oh yeah if you're on Tick Tock
live sometime I keep trying to see if
you're live do you gotta connect but I
don't understand anything about how you
go live where you go live when you go
live
I used to go live from like 10 to 2 A.M
but like what do you do during the day
nothing because you work you go live at
10 p.m dude it's because when I was
working that's when I would get off of
work it was like nine something I would
go home and that's when I would get on
live okay and so I feel like why would I
change the schedule if it's even though
you could hang out all day that's kind
of awesome that's badass I literally do
nothing yeah that's awesome yeah you
watch TV no
scared the wall literally scroll through
Tick Tock
um no probably like go like with my
family or with my friends out somewhere
and then come home to go live
that's awesome dude yeah that's the life
right there yeah it's pretty cool I
enjoy it way better than whatever the
hell I was I was looking for this
all right well uh I hope you enjoy your
time in LA yeah
thanks again man all the links are in
the description
um YouTube Instagram Twitter tick tock
you going live tonight no I used to go
live from Monday to Thursday on the
weekends dude you got like a whole ass
yeah schedule it's just like I don't
know I just feel like it's like would
you ever write the schedule in so people
know when to find you actually they know
um now but I've done it so many times
Monday through Thursday yeah 10 p.m
Central Time
to 2 A.M usually it's 2 A.M sometimes I
go even longer than that
it's funny though the middle of the
night yeah Vibes is kind of funny and
weird too yeah and people are always
like and they want me to go live earlier
but then like when I tried to go live
earlier they were like get off get off
now because we're at work still oh
people are annoying and I'm like okay
and I just got up and I still just use
the same schedule I don't know yeah it's
worked out so far maybe I'll change it
here and there
guys go follow uh go follow everywhere
and support we love support black people
oh your YouTube gained 5 000 Subs
already period thank you guys watching
your drunk ass oh my God you're sweaty
drunk ass
that was two years ago I promise I'm not
drunk anymore but I'm still sweaty yeah
yeah I know that well I'm also drunk
yeah yeah I know that too all right
everybody thanks for watching fantastic
great time we had here uh we'll be back
on Monday as usual for another great
week of shows isn't that right then
that's right you're looking at me like
there's something to say
there's a
oh
oh Zach's video the master Zach video
lore video it's two hours long you guys
and it's dropping tomorrow the Zach
t-shirt film let's go here we finished
rendering during this episode there you
go it's uh it's gonna be so much fun I'm
excited for you guys all to watch that
uh all right everybody have a great
weekend appreciate you see you next uh
love your special Peter
[Music]
thank you